[Musique]
les chefs sont prêts les citoyens
attendent des réponses place au débat
bonjour ça va bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
changer d'air pour ne pas peur de
s'engager pour l'avenir
nous on a un projet de société
on a décidé de s'assumer
[Applaudissements]
historique on va exprimer ce que
[Musique]
le peuple
en direct de la nouvelle Maison de
Radio-Canada à Montréal voici le débat
des chefs 2022 avec patrice Roy
bonsoir mesdames et messieurs bienvenue
à ce dernier débat de la campagne nous
sommes en effet en direct de la nouvelle
Maison de Radio-Canada à Montréal avec
nous François Legault chef la coalition
à venir Québec monsieur Legault bonsoir
bonsoir merci d'être là Dominique
Anglade chef du Parti libéral du Québec
madame bonsoir Paul Saint-Pierre
Plamondon au chef du Parti québécois
bonsoir Gabriel Nadaud Dubois co
porte-parole de Québec solidaire bonsoir
et Eric duem chef du Parti conservateur
du Québec bonsoir bonsoir merci d'avoir
accepté de débattre ce soir vous êtes
cinq et c'est une première cette année
pourquoi 5 c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire du Québec cinq parties ont
des chances de faire élire au moins un
député les positions sur le plateau
ainsi que l'ordre de parole ont été
évidemment tirés au hasard cinq thèmes
ce soir environnement
coût de la vie économie évidemment
sentez préoccupations éternelle
éducation et finalement immigration et
identité ce soir ma seule tâche sera de
vous permettre d'aller au bout de vos
idées dans l'ordre et le respect je vous
demande de ne pas parler les uns sur les
autres je vais vous donner l'occasion de
répliquer quand un chef est attaqué vous
aurez le temps de répliquer parlant de
temps pour votre temps de parole nous
visons une zone paritaire ça se dit bien
mais les gens pourront suivre à
l'occasion votre temps cumulatif sur un
tableau avant de passer au premier thème
petite question question se réchauffer
vous êtes tous brillants intelligent
vous pourriez faire autre chose dans la
vie mais vous aspirez à être première ou
Premier ministre question est simple
pourquoi pourquoi je reprends votre
expression monsieur
pourquoi vous imposer cette raide 45
secondes chacun je me considère chanceux
dans la vie je viens d'un milieu
populaire puis petit gars de Sainte-Anne
de Bellevue est rendu Premier ministre
et moi mon objectif ça serait tous les
jeunes et tous les outils pour aller au
bout de leur potentiel je pense que du
travail à faire en éducation je pense
qu'on peut faire mieux en économie on a
un grand défi de réduire nos GES c'est
un gros défi de gestion en santé c'est
important là pour moi de protéger notre
français d'arrêter le déclin qu'on voit
donc c'est pour toutes ces raisons que
je m'implique en politique merci
monsieur Legault Dominique Anglade la
question simplement c'est pourquoi faire
la politique pourquoi vous êtes ici
pourquoi vous imposez cette vie
merci de la question je je suis né de
parents qui ont décidé de choisir le
Québec comme terre d'accueil à la plus
de 50 ans les haïtiens qui sont venus
ici ils m'ont inculqué des valeurs
d'engagement et c'est valeurs là je les
incule quotidiennement à mes enfants
puis la raison pour laquelle
fondamentalement je fais de la politique
c'est parce que je souhaite que chaque
personne au Québec peu importe ses
origines peu importe où il habite sur
notre territoire qui soit capable de
vivre dignement puis d'aller au bout de
ses rêves puis c'est valeurs là que je
souhaite avoir qui vont m'habiter comme
première ministre du Québec c'est pour
ça fondamentalement que je fais de la
politique Gabriel Nadaud Dubois vous
avez 45 secondes pour répondre à la même
question bonsoir Monsieur roi bonsoir à
mes collègues bonne question de départ
monsieur Roy moi je suis en politique
parce que je m'inquiète pour l'avenir
parce que l'élection qui est la nôtre en
ce moment au Québec c'est celle de la
dernière chance pour la lutte au
changement climatique je suis devenu
papa récemment je rencontre des jeunes
parents presque tous les jours dans la
rue depuis le début de la campagne
électorale puis il y en a beaucoup du
monde inquiet pour l'avenir au Québec la
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on est capable
d'y arriver on a de l'énergie propre en
revanche on a toutes les cartes en main
pour devenir un des pays les plus verts
au monde moi ce que j'aimerais qu'on
fasse le 3 octobre c'est pas juste qu'on
pense à nous qu'on va aller voter mais
c'est qu'on pense à nos enfants et à nos
petits-enfants parce qu'on a du pain sur
la planche mais je pense qu'on est
capable d'y aller merci Gabriel adieu
Dubois pas le simply pierre plat Mondon
45 secondes
et moi je pense qu'il faut faire de la
politique pour aider des gens je pense
la politique peut servir à ça c'est être
utile au fond il y a plein de manières
d'être utile dans une société mais je
pense que la politique est l'une d'entre
elles c'est particulier faire de la
politique au Québec parce que c'est une
histoire riche belle et improbable on
parle toujours français depuis les
patriotes il y a toujours eu des gens
pour servir notre destinational pour
qu'un jour on soigne une société normale
qui rayonne partout dans le monde on
soigne société qui est démocratique
libre de ses propres choix et ce destin
il est pas encore il n'est pas encore
atteint mais moi c'est une fierté c'est
un privilège de servir des causes
fondamentales comme notre démocratie la
langue française l'environnement la
dignité des aînés je pense que ça peut
être utile en société merci
Eric Dumet en conclusion 45 secondes
mais très honnête même sur ouais je moi
je n'avais pas planifié de revenir en
politique mais pour moi la démocratie
fondamentale j'ai déjà mis ma vie en jeu
pour aller à l'étranger pour faire la
promotion de valeur des idéales
démocratiques et j'en étais rendu au
Québec où je voyais quatre parties il y
en avait aucun qui me représentait
j'aurais même pas pu voter en fait et je
me suis dit ça a pas de sens il faut
faire quelque chose moi si je suis
revenu en politique c'est parce que je
veux promouvoir les droits civiques les
libertés individuelles et la démocratie
j'ai l'impression qu'elle était mise à
mal et qui avait très peu de différence
entre les quatre parties qui restaient
je croyais que c'était important
d'offrir une alternative au Québécois et
je pense qu'à ce moment-là j'étais la
bonne personne au bon endroit au bon
moment et c'est pour ça que je suis ici
ce soir je pense que il y en a besoin
d'une alternative actuellement au Québec
merci Monsieur Duhem c'était la question
sympathique de la soirée
ça va il y en aura d'autres un peu
différent premier thème l'environnement
l'environnement
je trouve que c'est vraiment un enjeu
important
tout est relié à environnement la santé
l'économie il devrait faire des choses
qu'on consomme moins que les biens dure
longtemps promouvoir l'économie durable
mais j'étais d'accord que ça soit sur le
tapis mais là ça parle que ça veut
relever le tapis
mais la fonderie c'est vrai que ça a des
répercussions majeures
de l'écho anxiété
vous transports
de ça je pense il faut prévoir un pont
c'est plus facile parce que l'argent
pour l'urgence climatique quand même
dans un tournant où on peut bientôt puis
pouvoir revenir en arrière quelle est
votre plan environnemental dans les cinq
prochaines années pour en 2050
alors c'est exactement la question que
je vous posais vous avez d'abord 35
secondes pour y répondre monsieur
Legault quel est votre mesure qui va
faire la différence pas en 2050 comme a
dit Monsieur carrier de Saguenay
d'abord ce qui est important c'est
d'agir dans les 5 endroits où il y a des
grs le transport on a beaucoup de
projets de transport collectifs
deuxièmement les industries il faut que
les industries passent à l'électricité
donc acier vert aluminium vert hydrogène
verte je pense qu'on a la meilleure
équipe économique pour faire une
économie verte ensuite l'agriculture
faut vendre plus et acheter plus
localement il y a aussi toute la
question du recyclage donc recyclage des
contenants finalement les bâtiments
l'énergie pop c'est important
l'efficacité énergétique merci Monsieur
Lego Dominique Anglet 35 secondes il y a
quelqu'un dans le voxcobar qui a dit
tout est relié à l'environnement puis
c'est vrai la lutte au changement
pratique là je vais en faire ma
responsabilité parce que ça touche la
santé l'éducation l'économie les
ressources naturelles puis ça c'est ça
qui est fondamental et essentiel et dans
tout ce qu'on va proposer évidemment
qu'on va parler de l'agriculture
évidemment qu'on va parler de la lutte
au changement climatique mais ce qu'on
veut d'abord et avant tout c'est ne pas
avoir à opposer environnement économie
c'est de faire un projet qui soit
capable de créer de la richesse et en
même temps de faire en sorte qu'on soit
carbon neutre en 2050 c'est ça
l'objectif mais c'est pas qu'on planifie
merci
on a déposé un plan complet et rigoureux
vis-à-vis les changements climatiques et
ce plan a été applaudi par les experts
c'est important de mentionner qu'ici il
y a juste deux parties sur cinq qui ont
déposé un plan complet qui prévoit de
baisser les GS et de les mesurer et donc
notre plan il permet d'une transition
vers la nouvelle économie verte et juste
et on parle en termes très positif donc
les pas question de
réaliser ou de parler de dernière chance
mais vraiment de dire tous ensemble on
est capable de relever ce défi là
gagnant-gagnant merci pour tous Gabriel
ado Dubois 35 secondes et après je vous
rappelle on va passer au débat ouvert
après monsieur dumm mais Monsieur
Gabriel ado Dubois d'abord
mais moi je pense qu'en 2022 on peut
plus traiter de la question de
l'environnement des changements
climatiques comme d'une question
communaute ça doit être la colonne
vertébrale de notre projet de société au
Québec faire du Québec je le dis souvent
le pays le plus vert au monde on est
capable de le faire puis monsieur carry
avait bien raison de dire faut arrêter
de parler de 2050 faut que ça commence
maintenant parce que ça fait des
décennies au Québec qu'on pète le
problème par en avant puis quand on fait
ça qu'est-ce qu'on fait ben on est en
train de monter toute une facture pour
nos enfants nos petits-enfants moi
j'accepte pas ça je veux qu'on agisse
maintenant qu'il y a Québec solidaire ça
va commencer le 14 merci
Eric dum 35 secondes ou parce
conservateur du Québec on a une approche
très différente des quatre autres
parties nous on croit qu'il faut faire
comme par exemple la Norvège et il faut
justement se servir de nos hydrocarbures
sur notre territoire pour financer la
transition énergétique l'électrification
de nos transports parce qu'il y a un
coût à ça et il faut il faut trouver de
l'argent quelque part nous on pense qui
ont justement son exploit nos carbures
chez nous on va pouvoir avoir justement
moins à l'échelle planétaire et on va
pouvoir également financer
l'électrification de nos transports dans
l'ensemble des régions du Québec c'est
pas on peut pas demander des sacrifices
aux gens sans leur dire exactement
qu'est-ce qui va se passer comme les
quatre autres parties on pense qu'il
faut donner leur juste au quai très bien
Éric merci le débat ouvert commence on a
15 minutes une quinzaine de minutes pour
parler d'environnement c'était la
journée mondiale aujourd'hui sans
voiture la Journée mondiale sans voiture
les transports au Québec sont
responsables de la moitié des GES
comment réduire le nombre de voitures
qui augmentent deux fois plus vite que
la population du Québec actuellement
encore en 2022
sans taxer les véhicules polluants Paul
Saint-Pierre Plamondon vous commencez ce
débat ouvert vous vous êtes contre une
taxe pour les auto polluants non je suis
pas contre mais à court terme je dis on
a l'obligation de donner aux gens des
options si on taxe l'achat de véhicule à
essence l'an prochain mais que les gens
ont pas plus de transport collectif et
ils n'ont pas plus de voitures
électriques en vente ben on appauvrit
les gens puis c'est pas très productif
sur le plan de l'envie de voter en
fonction de l'environnement on propose
de doubler les transports collectifs
contraignent les fabricants et les
concessionnaires avant des véhicules
électriques avec des cibles similaires à
ce qui se fait en Europe en Californie
et on veut une passe climat 365 dollars
par année transport et à travers le
Québec de manière à encourager le
transport collectif mais également une
mesure économique qui met de l'argent
dans la poche des gens Gabriel ado
Dubois votre taxe sur une longue va
changer de modèle de voiture on est un
autre débat mais grande caravane 5000
dollars à peu près
trois enfants qui étaient sur le bas oui
je pense qu'on a un sujet qui est
important d'abord moi je trouve ça noble
ce que propose monsieur Nadaud Dubois
d'aller plus vite que le 37 et demi pour
cent mais faut quand même regarder les
impacts sur les citoyens quand vous
dites monsieur nado Dubois vous voulez
mettre une taxe orange de
7500 dollars sur une fourgonnette
familiale que vous voulez aussi fermer
des entreprises que vous voulez
augmenter la dette de 40% en
investissant 74 milliards mais moi j'ai
l'impression que c'est un peu comme de
la magie c'est un peu comme si vous
étiez au pays des merveilles monsieur
nado Dubois
devriez ranger les décorations
d'Halloween un petit peu là arrêtez de
faire peur aux gens vous devriez
inspirer les Québécois québécoises
proposer des solutions dans les
dernières semaines ce que vous avez fait
sur tout là c'est désinformer les
Québécois sur le plan Québec solidaire
votre Ministre Simon ce matin à la radio
disait Québec solidaire votre taxer les
véhicules usagers c'est pas vrai faut
arrêter de faire peur au monde on a
besoin de politiciens rassembleur qui
mobilise les gens qui les encouragent à
faire des choix écologiques pas de gens
qui les découragent
décourager le monde monsieur Lego sur la
taxe sur cette question là c'est très
concret pour le monde vous dites on peut
pas faire ça on voit deux exemples ici
d'un côté l'environnement c'est pas
fondamental avec la carte de l'autre
côté on a des gens qui veulent taxer des
personnes des citoyens alors qu'on
manque d'oxygène la proposition qu'on
fait est-ce qu'on est capable d'avoir un
véritable projet de société puis de se
dire qu'on est capable de lutter contre
les changements climatiques parce que
c'est l'enjeu du 21e siècle c'est quand
la dernière fois que tous les Québécois
ont été réunis les syndicats le patronat
les organismes communautaires la société
civile pour se dire on va se donner un
élan on va se donner un véritable projet
de société puis c'est ça qu'on propose
avec le projet écho où on est capable de
combiner l'écologie et l'économie on
n'est pas obligé de taxer les gens pour
le faire et ce qu'on a besoin de faire
c'est de se dire on va investir dans
l'éolien on va investir dans le solaire
on va investir dans l'hydrogène vert et
on va parvenir à atteindre nos objectifs
de carbone neutralité c'est ça qu'on a
besoin de faire c'est ça qu'on propose
on n'est pas obligé de parler que
d'économie puis de se donner aucune
cible crédible en environnement ou de
parler d'environnement avec des
pénalités qui vont à court terme créer
plus de problèmes probablement que de
solution on peut joindre les deux dans
un plan qui est rigoureux et qui vise
juste et nous c'est ce qu'on offre c'est
ce qu'on veut faire aux parties
québécois
passez moi l'expression on pèse sur le
gaz écoutez c'est pas ça le l'idée c'est
de dire on est tous pas une famille de
Québécois à 5000 dollars pour acheter un
v.us parce qu'ils ont besoin de
transporter leur enfant puis leur chien
on trouve que ça a pas de bon sens et
mieux mais on vaut mieux que ça nous on
veut on veut détaxer les produits
usagers c'est-à-dire que les voitures
ont déjà été taxées quand elles sont
vendues on veut même les détaxer quand
elles sont revendus parce que des gens
qui ont normalement un peu moins de
revenus qu'on trouve que au niveau
équitable c'est plus ça serait beaucoup
mieux que ces gens-là ne paient pas de
taxes sur une voiture
usagée pour ce qui est de si on veut
réduire la pollution par le transport
nous ce qu'on veut faire on propose on
venait un projet pilote à Québec on
voudrait qu'il y ait le transport en
commun gratuit pour mesurer
véritablement l'appétit pour la
population j'ai pas le tramway
maintenant on est contre le tramway mais
pour le transport en commun gratuit à
Québec comme projet pilote pour voir
combien de personnes vont abandonner
leur deuxième voiture ou même leur
première voiture au profit du transport
en commun s'il y a véritablement une
appétit pour ça oui je vais revenir à
Monsieur nado du bois je l'ai pas
entendu nous féliciter pour le contrat
qu'on a signé avec New York ça va
retirer l'équivalent d'un million de
taux des routes maintenant je pense
monsieur Nadaud Dubois vous devez une
réponse au Québec vous avez dit la taxe
orange de 7500$ à vos pas s'appliquer
pour des familles de 3 enfants au Québec
85% des familles ont un ou deux enfants
ensuite vous avez dit la taxe orange
s'appliquera pas dans certaines régions
je pense les Québécois ont droit de
savoir quelle région
ce sont les régions elles-mêmes qui vont
moduler ce programme là parce qu'on peut
pas faire du murmure mais vous savez
quoi monsieur Legault au dernier débat
la semaine passée vous avez accusé
monsieur Duhem d'avoir tiré d'enchalot
durant la pandémie mais en environnement
là c'est exactement ça que vous faites
au lieu d'encourager les Québécois
québécoises avec un projet positif vous
voyez là tout le temps que vous prenez
ce soir un million de temps que vous
prenez ce soir pour attaquer Québec
solidaire au lieu de proposer un projet
positif très bien on va lancer le plus
grand chantier depuis la Révolution
tranquille du transport en commun pour
tous les régions pour qu'au Québec ce
soit aussi facile de se déplacer en
Europe merci qu'on est rendu là merci
rapidement Paul Saint-Pierre Plamondon
et Madame Anglade puis après je vous
relance une autre question de manière
très concrète on veut que les transports
en commun soient gratuits pour les
étudiantes et pour les personnes aînées
ça ça va véritablement encourager les
gens à se déplacer puis quand j'entends
le côté monsieur et Monsieur
particulier
je dois vous dire ça ressemble à ça à la
différence à la différence que on veut
également un projet de société un projet
de société où on est capable de se
donner les moyens d'arrivée à atteindre
la carbone neutralité et ça François
Legault vous ne le proposez pas parce
que fondamentalement au fond de vous là
la lutte au changement climatique ça ne
vous habite pas ça ne vous habite pas
alors que c'est ça l'enjeu du 21e siècle
l'enjeu du 21e siècle c'est de faire en
sorte que on soit capable de combiner
l'écologie et l'économie c'est tentant
pour des sujets importants de se pointer
du doigt moi je veux juste mentionner
deux éléments
premièrement il y a deux parties sur
cinq qui ont déposé un plan complet
chiffré sur le plan DGS ce n'est pas le
gouvernement qui pourtant avait 28
millions de dollars pour des études
qu'on a jamais vu sur le troisième bien
deuxième éléphant dans la pièce chaque
année l'équipe Québécois et les
Québécoises voit leurs impôts partir
vers Ottawa et se sont plus de 2
milliards de dollars versés au
pétrolière de l'Alberta en cadeau puis
en subvention donc si on est sérieux à
propos de l'environnement oui on va
faire un plan qu'on va faire notre part
mais on va également faire
l'indépendance du Québec pour que cesse
ces contributions
dans la pièce le troisième lien je pense
qu'il est l'élément
depuis le début de la campagne bon
je lance le débat puis tout le monde a
le droit de parole je le rappelle je
lance le débat monsieur le groupe est-ce
que des études où il y a pas d'études
d'abord actuellement en Québec et les
vies
il y a un an qu'on va faire un tunnel de
centre-ville à centre-ville c'est la
meilleure façon de faire la promotion
combien
donc
pense pas qu'un pont qui détruirait
l'île d'Orléans
c'est la bonne idée on a besoin d'un
lien nous on propose un tunnel monsieur
Lego c'est qui qui fait l'étude puis
combien ça coûte votre cette étude là
donc vous parlez
[Musique]
sur un tunnel centre-ville monsieur avec
4 voies ça fait un il y a 4 ans premier
titre même pas que je promets
aujourd'hui mais monsieur Lego on évolue
tout le monde évolue oui vous avez
évolué vous avez abandonné les gens de
la région
vous savez même pas qu'il fallait bien
fini conclué
aujourd'hui la une Journal de Québec là
c'est que le compte Québec pour être
démoli je sais pas si vous avez vu ça
après ça la semaine passée j'ai parlé à
monsieur Legault j'ai demandé s'il y
avait une effectivement une proposition
que deux voix sur le Pont Pierre Laporte
pour être fermé il m'a dit non en cas de
Radio-Canada prouvé que oui il y a eu
une édition il y a eu des échanges de
courriels et aujourd'hui nous dit qu'il
y a il serait bien sécuritaire je ne
fais pas peur au monde pourquoi ils ont
enlevé toutes les équipements sur le
pont monsieur Lego monsieur Lego moi
j'en ai une petite puis je vous jure je
vous donne les paroles à tout le monde
si votre étude montrent que c'est un
pont la meilleure option est-ce que vous
dites tant pis je vois quand même en
tunnel écoutez détruire le paysage d'une
des plus belles villes au pilons
détruire l'île d'Orléans avec une
autoroute
c'est pas une bonne idée ça l'était à
vous mais c'est ça le problème monsieur
Legault c'est que peu importe que la
science vous dit vous avez décidé que
vous allez dans une direction ça fait
quatre ans ça fait 4 ans qui sont au
gouvernement il y a aucune étude qui a
été rendue publique il y en a des études
il y en a des études qui ont été faites
mais on ne les voit pas on nous les
cache puis c'est ça l'enjeu par rapport
au troisième lien c'est que personne ne
sait on s'en va moi je vais vous dire
une affaire moi je suis ingénieur de
formation des plans puis des devis de
j'en ai vu dans ma vie j'en ai vu dans
ma vie il y a aucun plan aucun devis qui
a été présenté au bout de quatre ans
nous ce qu'on veut c'est faire les
études rapidement pour qu'on trouve des
solutions à la à Québec
je veux juste préciser le monsieur Lego
vous avez dit que c'était un projet qui
est politique et que étude poétude pour
des raisons politiques vous alliez le
faire c'est ce que vous avez déclaré
donc un moment donné études pour études
il procède pour des raisons
électoralistes et à tous les gens
traversent le Québec ça vous dit à quel
point les décisions de la CAQ sont
peu-fondées sur l'intérêt public et
pendant ce temps-là il y a des projets
de transport structurant dans l'est de
Montréal qui ont pas avancé pendant
quatre ans il y a un pont à Tadoussac
pour lequel on a déjà 14 étapes et
laquelle 14 études depuis 1973 puis vous
en voulez une autre pour celui-là mais
le troisième lien par exemple sur pas de
problème 8 10 12 milliards c'est parti
que les études que vous avez que vous
cachez au Québécois vous voulez pas les
montrer parce qu'ils sont périmés parce
que c'était avant la crise Center vous
avez dit ça on a entendu ça les études
qui ont été faites le tramway elles sont
aussi périmées parce qu'il y a 30% moins
d'usagers des autobus à Québec
présentement est-ce que vous allez
remettre le projet de tramway sur la
glace en attendant le renouvellement de
nouvelles études ou si ça c'est pas
pareil parce que le tramway vous êtes
pauvre puis alors que le troisième bien
vous voulez faire languir la population
les études sur le troisième lien c'était
un lien à l'est avec 6 projets avec 6
voies c'est ça qu'on propose nous ce
qu'on propose c'est un tunnel avec
quatre voix dont deux voix aux heures de
pointe qui sont pour le transport
collectif plutôt que de prendre 30
minutes ça va prendre 10 minutes pour ce
qui est du tramway ben écoutez d'une
grande ville comme Québec là on a donc
important la mise à jour passe pandémie
sur ce sur ce thème et je veux vous
parler
d'Hydro-Québec des barrages monsieur
Lego vous avez l'ancien campagne ça
prend des barrages est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord ou pas vous avez dit non dans
certains pour certains d'entrevue madame
en garde vous vous dites on n'a pas
besoin de nouveaux barrages on a besoin
de plus d'électricité puis ça passe par
l'éolien ça passe par le solaire ça
passe par l'économie d'énergie qu'on
fait ici au Québec puis ça passe par
l'hydrogène vert partout sur la planète
on se transforme sauf au Québec monsieur
Lego il va nous parler de barrage mais
ça c'était il y a déjà plusieurs années
là dans le siècle dernier aujourd'hui ou
21e siècle lorsqu'on propose comme
projet avec l'éolien c'est vraiment un
projet d'une génération c'est ça qu'on
propose sur le groupe barrage absolument
écoutez c'est mathématique si on regarde
les plans l'un des trois qui sont ici
c'est impossible avec
l'efficacité énergétique et l'éolien
parce que l'éolien c'est intermittent ça
prend des barrages ou du nucléaire nous
on dit Déborah maintenant comme à la
maglab parle d'hydrogène vers ça prend
beaucoup d'électricité mais pas capable
de nous dire où elle va prendre
l'électricité pour l'hydrogène vert ça
marche pas son affaire si on avait
écouté si on avait écouté monsieur
Legault quand le temps d'investir dans
le lien on l'aurait pas fait parce qu'il
nous disait que c'était trop cher si on
avait écouté monsieur Legault quand
c'était le temps d'investir dans la
bourse du carbone on l'aurait pas fait
parce que il nous disait qu'il croyait
pas vraiment là-dedans il faut anticiper
faut voir ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
dans l'hydrogène vers là c'est partout
sur la planète en Europe au Danemark en
Angleterre en Allemagne ils investissent
de manière massive et se transforme et
c'est là qu'on doit embarquer on doit
embarquer maintenant vos potes barrages
c'est à dire que Monsieur le goût promet
des barrages mais on sait pas sur quelle
rivière ça nous le dit jamais vous on
sait pas ils vont être construits mais
vous vous êtes français
nous on a un plan puis là-dessus je suis
d'accord avec Monsieur plamondo nos
plans nous là qui ont été modélisés par
une ferme spécialisée mon plan là il est
approuvé par huit experts indépendants
ça c'est 8 experts de plus que vous mais
ce plan l'a dit c'est qu'on a pas besoin
de nouveau barrage pour rappel donc
monsieur Legault les gens ont le choix
soit ils croient monsieur troisième lien
soit il croit les experts je pense
qu'ils vont choisir droits les excès moi
je crois qu'il faut diversifier nos
sources d'énergie on le sait qu'on va
avoir besoin de plus d'énergie c'est
pour ça que la partie conservateur on
est les seuls qui sont favorables à
l'exploitation de notre gaz mais on est
aussi favorable à développer plus de
filières hydroélectriques évidemment ok
environnemental je vais gruger sur le
temps les barrages ça peut être
nécessaire mais c'est pas démonter pour
l'instant mais ça ne doit pas être un
substitut à un plan en matière de
changement climatique et c'est ça que
Monsieur le goût à cette terre passez
les barrages comme si c'était un plan
vis-à-vis les changements climatiques
je vous change de sujets les vous allez
voir une carte apparaître les clins
miniers ça a doublé ça a doublé au
Québec et ça touche des milieux naturels
des milieux de villégiature laximon lac
des plages ou taouet Laurentides
les préfets vous demandent monsieur
Legault disent faites un moratoire il y
a pas d'acceptabilité sociale partout
oui faire le Québec la batterie de
l'Amérique du Nord mais le prix à payer
est-ce que c'est de détruire des milieux
auxquels on tient
d'abord je vais être très clair il y a
effectivement des milieux où il y a de
l'acceptabilité sociale puis il y a des
milieux où il y a pas d'acceptabilité
sociale quand il y a pas d'acceptabilité
sociale il y aura pas d'exploitation
donc c'est clair on va exploiter là où
le milieu est d'accord pour qu'on
travaille dans certaines mines est-ce
que là-dessus il y a en ce moment
monsieur roi un beau minier au Québec
puis c'est pas seulement une mauvaise
nouvelle parce qu'il y a de ce minerai
là qu'on a besoin pour la transition
écologique mais ça peut pas se faire
n'importe comment nous on va répondre
présent à la demande des élus municipaux
des gouvernements de proximité qui
disent là ça peut pas se faire n'importe
comment il fait bien moratoire
temporaire sur les nouveaux clins dans
les secteurs villégiature dans les
secteurs habités le temps qu'on se donne
au Québec un nouveau pack social minier
pour que ça se fasse comme du monde je
veux je veux l'accès acceptabilité
sociale environnement c'est exactement
ça acceptabilité sociale il faut
collaborer il faut collaborer avec les
il faut pas se poser avec les pieds
imposer des choix très bien bon j'avais
d'autres sujets d'environnement ça sera
pour un autre débat parce que des il y a
un sujet qui préoccupe les gens la
Réserve fédérale hier dit les taux
d'intérêt élevé le préparez-vous
messieurs dames on en a pour longtemps
peut-être jusqu'à 5%
coût de la vie économie
il y a un sujet qui vous préoccupe
surtout l'inflation le pouvoir d'achat
l'inflation me gruge des arts de sommeil
parce que
les pensions de vraiment monter parce
qu'on a pas beaucoup pour vivre
cher l'alimentation les prix c'est
exorbitants
et jeunes aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'ils
vont faire une maison un jour faudrait
que ça sur place ici à bientôt
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire pour baisser
l'inflation
l'argent qu'on gagne ne suffit pas
comment pensez-vous alléger les fardeaux
financier des familles québécoises
c'est peut-être la question que vous
avez la plus entendu sur la route de la
campagne électorale Paul Saint-Pierre
Plamondon d'abord chacun à 35 secondes
pour répondre tous les partis ici
promettent soit une baisse d'impôts soit
une baisse de taxes il y a que le Parti
québécois pour dire on ne donnera pas de
cadeau plus riche on hypothécropole
notre avenir mais on donne le soutien le
plus généreux de tous les parties ici
pour ceux qui gagnent en 0 et 50 000 une
remise de 1200$ d'ici la fin de l'année
en 50 000 et 80000 750 dollars
essentiellement on prend les surplus de
l'État en raison de l'inflation on leur
redonne à ceux qui ont de la misère à
rejoindre les deux bouts mais sans
s'attaquer au service public et sans
faire de cadeaux au plus riche ce qui
est malheureusement le défaut des autres
propositions
qui arrivent pas il y a des retraités
qui ont des petites pensions qui sont
mal pris et
contraire conscience que dit Monsieur
saint-pierre-lamondon c'est la CAQ en
2022 le maintenant qui offre le plus
d'argent dans le portefeuille on veut
donner 4 à 600 dollars au mois de
décembre à tous ceux qui gagnent moins
de 100000 puis on veut donner 2000
dollars de plus à partir de 2022 au 70
ans et plus puis après on va baisser les
impôts merci
Eric Duhem 35 secondes mais nous le
Parti conservateur du Québec on est le
parti qui offre les plus importantes
baisse d'impôts de tous les partis
politiques à l'heure actuelle et on
propose également de suspendre la taxe
sur l'essence justement pour donner du
répit aux familles du Québec pour que ça
soit le gouvernement qui se sert la
ceinture dans ses dépenses plutôt que
les familles du Québec qui souffrent
présentement nos bases d'impôts sont
tellement généreuses pour une famille
par exemple avec deux enfants qui
gagnent 80000 dollars c'est plus de 3000
dollars de baisse d'impôts annuellement
récurrent je pense que c'est le genre de
politique que les gens ont besoin pour
pouvoir arriver parce que sinon on y
arrivera pas et c'est de loin le sujet
dont on parle le plus merde depuis le
début de la campagne aussi Dominique
Anglade 35 secondes mais à tous ceux qui
nous écoutent vous l'avez entendu dans
le vox-pop il y en a qui doivent choisir
entre payer l'épicerie payer le logement
puis ça crée énormément d'incertitudes
puis d’angoisse nous ce qu'on veut c'est
retourner l'argent dans les poches des
familles 5000 dollars par famille
concrètement c'est pas un chèque qui va
être envoyé une fois c'est quelque chose
qui va être récurrent année après année
l'autre volet qui hyper important c'est
que la seule chose qui augmente pas là
c'est le revenu de nos aînés c'est pour
ça qu'on a besoin d'avoir une allocation
pour aînée de 2000 dollars par année
année après année pas un chèque ça vient
chaque année dans les poches de nausées
merci Gabriel Nadaud Dubois conclusion
35 secondes c'est une question en effet
qui nous est souvent posée qu'on se
promène qu'on rencontre des gens sur le
terrain puis il y a beaucoup de choses à
faire pour aider les gens à se sortir de
cette crise du coût de la vie je dois
vous nommer nos deux priorités d'abord
il faut donner un congé de tes vécus sur
les biens essentiels ça veut dire pas de
TVQ à l'épicerie à la pharmacie au
terrain sur les vêtements ou pour faire
des réparations par exemple de sa
voiture ça c'est plus de 1000 dollars
d'économies pour une famille au Québec
et la deuxième affaire à faire c'est
réglé la crise du logement c'est le
premier poste de dépenses des familles
on réglera pas la crise du coût de la
vie si on règle pas la crise du logement
merci il y a donc deux camps vous l'avez
dit ceux qui proposent des baisses
d'impôts monsieur Legault madame
anglaise monsieur dum et ceux qui sont
contre Monsieur Saint-Pierre platmandon
et Monsieur Nadaud Dubois
baisser les impôts monsieur Legault
c'est vous qui lancez le bloc ouvert ce
n'est pas aussi réduire les services
publics bon d'abord nous ce qui est le
plus important ce sont les montants
ponctuels qu'on donne en 2022 4 à 600
dollars en décembre puis 2000 dollars
pour les personnes de 70 ans et plus les
baisses d'impôts commencent l'année
prochaine sont moins élevés que le Parti
libéral est parti conservateur parce
qu'on pense qu'il faut agir à court
terme maintenant
économiquement là on a besoin de
soulager les contribuables de donner un
institatif au travail on est dans le
plafond au Canada en Amérique du Nord
pour les impôts vraiment
plus importantes que les baisses
proposées par la CAQ est-ce que ce n'est
pas maître de l'huile sur le feu avec
cette spirale inflationniste parce que
vous touchez à des gens quand même qui
ont des bons revenus
non ça l'est pas parce que on a besoin
d'avoir des gens qui puissent vraiment
faire face au coup de la vie mais
l'autre manière dont on a approché le
problème c'est vraiment de se dire que
les gens de la classe moyenne qu'on
diminue leur impôts mais que les gens
qui sont capables de contribuer
davantage les gens qui gagnent plus de
300 000 dollars l'argent qui dort dans
les paradis fiscaux l'argent que les
grandes banques ou les grandes sociétés
d'assurance peuvent donner qui soient
capables de contribuer on est le parti
qui fait en sorte que on descend les
impôts pour la classe moyenne mais on
demande aussi à ceux qui sont capables
d'en payer davantage de faire leur part
puis c'est comme ça qu'on a une société
qui soit juste puisqu'il est équitable
monsieur
reproché de ratisser pas mal large avec
votre notion de riche avec des biens qui
peuvent valoir oui un million mais après
une vie complète d'économie est-ce que
vous ratissez pas effectivement assez
large moi je pense que le 5% le plus
riche au Québec on les moyens de
contribuer un peu plus puissant ça ça va
être bon pour 100% des Québécois
québécois ça va nous donner des
meilleurs écoles des meilleurs hôpitaux
des meilleurs CHSLD on va pouvoir
investir pour vrai dans l'environnement
et ça va nous permettre de baisser les
factures de tout le monde au Québec on
va faire baisser la facture du dentiste
parce qu'on va mettre en place une
assurance dentaire public et universelle
ça coûte un bras à l'échelle dentiste on
va faire baisser la facture de la
rentrée scolaire on va baisser les
tarifs de transport en commun de 50 %
pour faire ça ça prend des
investissements ça prend de l'argent et
oui moi je pourrais gêné dire on va
aller chercher cet argent là chez le 5%
le plus riche au Québec les quatre
autres parties ont pas ce courage là moi
je pense qu'on est rendu un Malaisie
mais moi ce que je veux dire c'est que
oui on est on a des bases d'impôts mais
contrairement aux parties libéral et à
la CAQ on veut pas aller piger ça dans
les poches la prochaine génération
j'étais très surpris pour pas dire déçu
quand j'ai vu monsieur le coup manquer
d'équité envers les générations en
allant piger l'argent dans le fond des
générations je trouve ça
particulièrement irresponsable on a déjà
un problème d'équité intergénérationnels
on est déjà en train d'appauvrir la
prochaine génération puis vous en
ajouter une couche en allant essayer
d'acheter la prochaine élection en
hypothéquant l'avenir de la prochaine
génération j'ai pas trouvé ça que
c'était la plus brillante des idées
madame Anglade c'est beau de baisser les
impôts mais quand après ça vous dites
que vous voulez augmenter le déficit de
façon considérable vous aussi c'est une
façon indirecte de pelleter le problème
sur le dos de la prochaine génération on
est les seuls qui proposons des baisses
d'impôts qui sont responsables
c'est-à-dire que on va le piger dans
l'argent qu'on a actuellement plutôt que
d'hypothéquer la prochaine génération
juste une petite chose combien de
fonctionnaires vous mettez à la porte
parce que vos coupures sont assez
élevées on propose essentiellement ce
que monsieur Legault proposait il y a 4
ans qu'il n'a pas rempli comme promesse
on voudrait réduire de 5000 le nombre
d'employés de l'État cela étant dit on
veut pas congédié personne parce que
vous savez que notre fonction publique
au Québec elle est vieillissante on
voudrait fonctionner par attrition donc
on voudrait mais on veut réduire la
taille de l'État contrairement monsieur
le goût on va pas dire une chose faire
le contraire si on est élu juste pour
des fins de rigueur les parties qui
promettent des baisses d'impôts c'est
réduire les revenus de l'État et
mettez-vous dans une situation par
exemple de récession hypothétique
ça veut dire un autre cycle d'austérité
pour les travailleurs du public de la
santé c'est un aller simple vers le
stérilité et c'est un cadeau au plus
riche pour ce qui est de la baisse de
taxes que Québec solidaire propose c'est
peut-être que un contribution 300 400
dollars pour quelqu'un qui gagne 30 000
mais pour quelqu'un qui gagne 300000 par
exemple c'est un bon 222 dollars si vous
l'avez dans un restaurant de luxe vous
achetez des choses de luxe la remise au
plus riche est beaucoup plus grande que
celle à ceux qui en ont besoin donc nous
au Parti québécois on dit
concentrons-nous sur les gens et les
familles qui ont de la misère à
rejoindre les deux bouts pas de cadeaux
au plus riche et surtout pas à
s'attaquer hypothéquer nos services
publics
va devoir répondre du fait que quand
lorsqu'on regarde les il veut faire des
révisions de programme dans son cadre
financier va nous dire où est-ce qu'il
va aller chercher les montants d'argent
par rapport aux prévisions de programme
mais je suis d'accord avec Monsieur Paul
Saint-Pierre à Mondon quand il dit on
est on doit aussi faire en sorte que les
gens qui soient plus riches contribuent
c'est pour ça que notre programme on a
justement ça on va demander aux gens qui
sont capables de contribuer davantage de
plus de 300000 dollars de le faire ça
c'est ce qu'on appelle une véritable
équité oui on est capable de baisser les
impôts pour la classe moyenne et
demander aux gens qui sont capables de
contribuer d'en faire plus c'est ça la
justice sociale également
on avait un écart de richesse de 16%.
c'était comme ça depuis 10 ans avec
l'Ontario on aurait dû ça à 13%. donc
faut attirer plus d'investissements les
entreprises mais moi j'ai une question
pour Monsieur nado Dubois qui a dit je
le cite il y a des secteurs de notre
économie qui certainement doivent
décroître donc je pense les Québécois
ont le droit de savoir quelles
entreprises dans quelle région vous
voulez les fermer dans quelle région
vous voulez fermer des entreprises c'est
ce que vous avez dit
c'est pas ce que j'ai dit Monsieur
legoomie mondiale change le secteur du
pétrole le secteur du gaz les
raffineries on est en 2022 c'est secteur
là ils vont se transformer mais oui ils
vont être plus fragiles la demande en
pétrole et en gaz vont plafonner au
Québec il va plafonner dans le monde
c'est une tendance mondiale
1994 la nouvelle économie c'est
l'économie verte nous notre vision se
développements économique c'est de
encourager les secteurs d'avenir et
accompagner dans cette
transitions
arrêtez de sortir les décorations dans
le win arrêtez de faire peur au monde
l'API des merveilles
Search est sorti un sondage justement
sur l'exploitation du gaz naturel au
Québec ils ont demandé au Québec une
bonne idée d'exporter notre gaz naturel
vers l'Europe pour remplacer le gaz
russe il y a 60% des Québécois qui
disent oui vous êtes quatre parties à
dire non vous êtes en train de dire non
à une industrie vous avez déjà été en
faveur monsieur Lego vous promettiez sûr
vous avez cru un chapitre entier dans
votre livre cap sur un Québec gagnant
pour l'action puis aujourd'hui vous
voulez plus rien savoir et là vous êtes
en train de faire poursuivre vous mettez
le Québec à risque de devoir des
milliards de dollars et des entreprises
à qui vous aviez donné des droits et
vous êtes en train de les retirer
unilatéralement monsieur Legault à quoi
vous jouez
vous vous l'exploiter du gaz puis du
pétrole nous on veut développer
l'électricité incluant des barrages
contrairement aux trois parties qui sont
ici très bien
vous écoutez tous ces messieurs discuter
et à la fin de la journée là aujourd'hui
un éléphant dans la pièce de point de
vue économique puis le descend dans la
pièce qui s'appelle la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre il s'appelle le fait que on n'a
pas suffisamment de personnes puis au
début c'était un enjeu qui était
économique mais il est devenu social
parce qu'on n'a pas de monde dans nos
écoles parce qu'on n'a pas de monde un
service de la santé puis monsieur Lego
vous disiez en 2018 on va en prendre
moins c’était votre slogan on va en
prendre moins puis on va prendre soin
puis la réalité c'est que dans les
quatre dernières années on a pris moins
de pharmacies moins d'infirmières moins
de préposés au bénéficiaires et le
résultat c'est que on a moins de soins
et moins de service et la population le
ressent partout partout l'enjeu de la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre frappe de plein
fouet on parle d'économie là ça fait 12
minutes qu'on débat présentement de
l'enjeu de la pénurie de main d'oeuvre
il y a rien qui a été fait de manière
concrète
les salaires ont jamais augmenté aussi
vite qu'actuellement les travailleurs
sont contents maintenant la solution là
augmenter la productivité des
entreprises
requalifier ceux qui étaient par exemple
dans le secteur du détail c'est pas vrai
que la seule solution c'est
l'immigration ça vous intéresse pas de
protéger le français ça vous intéresse
pas au sujet si je peux me permettre le
sujet c'est le coût de la vie j'aimerais
qu'on y revienne
parlons d'éléphants dans la pièce il y
en a un que je veux nommer les
pétrolières ont fait 29 milliards de
profits dans les 6 derniers mois qu'on a
pu mesurer ça ça veut dire que l'argent
des Québécoises et les Québécois là elle
est siphonnée à la pompe par des gens
qui volent qui nous volent c'est un
cartel qui agit en violation de toutes
les règles de concurrence et à ma
connaissance le Parti québécois et le
seul parti à vouloir s'attaquer à ces
pétrolières en disant on va imposer vos
surprofis puis on va exercer un contrôle
sur la concurrence parce que c'est du
vol et on peut pas imprimer des fonds
publics pour que sa transite quelques
secondes dans le portefeuille des
Québécois pour ensuite s'en aller dans
les paradis fiscaux dans des compagnies
multinationales
est-ce que c'est possible de taxer les
pétrolières au Québec il y a un prix
Nobel si on taxe les pétrolières ils
vont répercuter son prix
ça a fonctionné monsieur Legault le prêt
à la pompe en Ontario moins cher
pourquoi vous faites pas ça pourquoi
vous donnez pas un break
4 à 600 dollars puis laisser la liberté
aux gens ça vous dit quelque chose la
liberté
que d'imposer ça se fait Royaume-Uni non
mais il y a un prix Nobel qui a 5 jours
et sorti pour dire c'est ça qu'il faut
faire donc avant de dire que c'est
impossible voyons ce qu'ils se font sur
fait de mieux à l'étranger sur les
experts sur les pétrolières madame
Anglade puis monsieur Dubois ensuite
l'enjeu fondamental honnêtement là c'est
pas d'aller
c'est parce que l'enjeu fondamental en
train de passer à côté monsieur Roy le
l'enjeu économique essentiel aujourd'hui
monsieur Legault il aime beaucoup se
comparer à l'Ontario mais on a créé
trois fois moins il a créé trois fois
moins d'emplois que l'Ontario mais c'est
mais c'est vrai monsieur Legault et en
plus en plus dans tous les secteurs
d'énergie il est obsédé par le par
l'Ontario mais la réalité c'est que la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre c'est le frein
essentiel qu'on a aujourd'hui partout
les vont vous le dire d'un point de vue
économique ça ne tient pas la route
pénurie de main d'oeuvre on fait quoi
mais nous on pense qu'il faut d'abord
ramener les aînés qui veulent travailler
on veut que les gens de 60 ans et plus
puissent avoir des crédits d'impôts
supplémentaires pour venir même c'est
juste un jour deux jours trois jours ça
va être du mentorat ça va être
l'expertise qu'on a besoin ça va être
également un une socialisation pour ces
personnes là nous on pense qu'il faut
vraiment investir sur nos aînés Gabriel
du bon fait quoi pénurie de main
d'oeuvre on fait quoi l'immigration
c'est pas la solution magique à la
pénurie de main-d'oeuvre mais c'est une
partie de la solution nos régions ont
besoin de renfort moi quand je me
promène depuis le début de la campagne
c'est les entreprises mais c'est aussi
les travailleurs travailleuses tout le
monde le dit c'est aussi le secteur
public on a besoin de bras on a besoin
de renfort quand on accueille plus
d'immigrants d'immigrants on gonfle
notre population active ça fait en sorte
que plus de monde à l'ouvrage ça va nous
donner des meilleurs services publics au
Québec moi quand je me promène dans les
régions c'est ça que j'entends am tout
du monde en renfort puis nous on va le
faire par Saint-Pierre Plamondon pénurie
de main d'oeuvre les économistes de
référence disent que d'augmenter les
seuils ça ne compte pas la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre par exemple en Ontario ils
ont accueilli un million de personnes en
disant sont toujours en pénurie de main
d'oeuvre ce qu'on peut faire par contre
c'est augmenter la participation au
travail notamment en permettant aux
parents d'avoir une place garantie en
CPE c'est ce qu'on propose augmenter la
participation du travail des aînés on
offre une baisse du taux d'imposition
pour les aînés les derniers éléments
parce que on passe toujours à côté de ce
sujet là il y a des régions au Québec où
on investit moins en infrastructure où
on investit moins en termes d'économie
c'est vrai pour l'Est du Québec la côte
nord l'Abitibi laisse de Montréal on est
le seul parti avoir mesuré ce déficit
d'investissement et on va très bien le
dire on va rendre justice pour que ce
soit écrit je reviens au coût de la vie
et une dernière table dernier tour de
table sur l'accès à la propriété on
vient de comparer avec l'Ontario là
c'est pas reluisant pour le Québec il y
a 59 9% des Québécois qui sont
propriétaires en Ontario c'est 68 là à
peu près donc on a un grave que le
comment faire pour améliorer l'accès la
propriété des gens qui nous écoutent qui
disent on peut plus acheter ce logo mais
la seule façon d'y arriver c'est de
créer de la richesse comme on a fait
contrairement à ce que dit Madame
anglais on a réduit notre écart
l'Ontario il faut créer des emplois
mieux payés aujourd'hui le défi c'est
créer des emplois c'est de créer des
emplois bien payés mieux payés c'est
comme ça qu'on va réduire notre écart de
richesse on va donner le moyen au
Québécois de s'acheter une maison de
s'acheter un condo c'est ça la façon
accès à la propriété voyez-vous vous
avez posé une question très claire sur
l'accès à la propriété sur le logement
et monsieur Legault ne répond pas à la
question parce qu'il y a nié ce problème
là pendant l'essentiel de son mandat la
crise du logement et la crise de l'accès
à la propriété là c'est les deux faces
d'une même médaille il faut agir sur les
deux plans construire plus de logements
sociaux et abordables limiter les
hausses de loyer abusives et lutter
contre la spéculation la surenchère qui
est en train de priver toute une
génération de l'accès à la propriété
accès à la propriété
cette question était très spécifique
Axel appropriété il y a plein de
personnes qui nous écoutent aujourd'hui
qui ont acheté qui ont des faits des
demandes pour acheter des maisons 14
fois 15 fois 16 fois on peut réussir à
acheter une maison nous on propose très
concrètement d'abolir la taxe de
bienvenue de compenser 100% les villes
par rapport à ça puis de faire en sorte
que s'ils veulent utiliser l'oreillette
ils veulent râper qu'on l'augmente
jusqu'à 50000 dollars ça très
concrètement ça va aider les gens qui
veulent acheter des propriétés c'est ça
la réponse à votre question à la
propriété nous aussi on pense qu'il faut
qu'effectivement avec la taxe de
bienvenue particulièrement pour les
jeunes familles soit abolies qu'on
compense les villes évidemment mais avec
la hausse des taux d'intérêt puis la
baisse du prix des maisons il y a les
jeunes n'auront pas plus accès à la
propriété le SEPA les deux vases font en
sorte qu'il y a pas de il y a pas de
solution magique parce que si les taux
d'intérêt côté mais c'est le prix des
maisons diminue il y aura pas plus la
possibilité d'accéder à la propriété
nous si je peux me permettre on veut
créer un crédit d'impôt pour les
premiers acheteurs en fait l'augmenter
mais c'est l'offre et la demande donc
ici il y a des parties qui veulent 50
000 70 80 000 augmenter les seuils l'an
prochain si c'est ça le seuil on n'aura
pas de nouveau logement là donc c'est
l'offre et la demande aussi qu'il faut
qu'il faut considérer on va en parler
tout à l'heure de l'immigration qu'on
reviendra puis vous direz ce que vous
voulez sur l'immigration effectivement
on pourra revenir sur la les liens qu'on
fait ou pas avec la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre thème autre sujet de
préoccupation des gens dans tous les
sondages la santé
en amont le système de santé doit être
amélioré à tous les niveaux un rôle
comme sur une crevaison depuis trop
longtemps
mais on peut servir ce qu'on avait
déjà soigner
des hôpitaux
d'externats et puis j'ai vu que les
infirmières étaient aboutissent je
travaille à l'urgence
si tu veux avoir un service médical
c'est compliqué si tu veux voir un
médecin
c'est encore plus compliqué
j'ai appelé pour prendre un rendez-vous
on m'a dit que je suis orpheline parce
que mon métier famille est à la retraite
moi ça fait 7 ans que j'ai pas de
médecin de famille donc c'est toujours
un problème de toujours de trouver mes 7
familles et ça c'est pas facile
on vend que médecin puis d'infirmière
mais ils encouragent pas à aller
travailler là comment vous allez aider à
gérer la crise dans les hôpitaux en ce
moment
alors vous connaissez mieux que nous ces
questions là qu'on vous pose quand vous
allez circuler dans la population
rituelle d'abord vous avez 35 secondes
chacun iridèmes le premier mais pour
nous il faut additionner la contribution
du secteur privé on croit que c'est
important de garder l'assurance
universelle publique c'est-à-dire que
notre carte d'assurance maladie va
continuer à payer pour nos soins de
santé mais si le gouvernement si l'État
n'est pas capable de fournir des soins
dans des délais raisonnables la personne
doit faire comme dans un paquet de pays
européen avoir la possibilité d'aller
dans un hôpital ou une clinique privée
et c'est sa carte d'assurance maladie
qui va payer pour ses soins et même
mieux que ça si les le privé capable de
le faire moins cher que le public elle
peut y aller même avant les délais il
peut y aller directement donc c'est
vraiment d'additionner la contribution
du privé pour merci Paul Saint-Pierre
Plamondon l'enjeu c'est qu'on n'écoute
pas les travailleurs dans le domaine de
la santé on les respecte pas
conditions de travail enfin pour les
soignants du Québec moi je pense qu'il
mérite merci François Legault oui ben
écoutez d'abord en 2018 on est hérité
d'un système de santé qui était malade
ensuite on a eu la pandémie depuis 2 ans
et demi et malgré ça on arrive sans
quelques mois à former 10000 préposés au
bénéficiaires on a réussi à ce qui est
300 000 Québécois de plus qu'a accès à
un groupe de médecine de famille puis
Christian Dubé a déposé un plan complet
évidemment ça prend trois ans mais des
infirmières donc il y a personne ici qui
peut faire de magie mais il faut y aller
graduellement puis il faut décentraliser
ce qui est de plus important merci
Dominique Anglade conclusion 35 secondes
moi je me dresser au 1 million de
Québécois qui ont pas de médecine de
famille on n'a pas le droit de baisser
les bras on a la responsabilité de
trouver des moyens pour vous permettre
d'avoir un médecin de famille surtout
les personnes qui ont deux maladies
chroniques qui vivent avec des enjeux de
présenter et aussi des enjeux de santé
mentale qui sont importants qui sont
répandues partout dans notre système
mais il faut également qu'on prenne soin
de notre monde puis prendre soin de
notre monde ça veut dire que il faut
arrêter le temps supplémentaire
obligatoire il faut l'éliminer puis
faire en sorte qu'on est des conditions
de travail acceptable pour toutes nos
professionnelles de la santé merci
Madame anglaise le débat ouvert commence
comment ça se fait que ça prend deux
semaines pour avoir un rendez-vous avec
un pneumologue ou privé deux semaines et
322 jours au public ça c'est 46 semaines
est-ce que plus de privés ce serait pas
une option qu'on devrait regarder
premier Gabriel ado Dubois vous lancez
le bal du Déborah la présence du privé
dans le système de santé augmente
d'année en année au Québec une
augmentation de 52% en 40 donc si le
privé en santé ça marchait on le saurait
ce qu'on voit
les agences privées de placement ça
marche pas les CHSLD privé ça marche pas
donc ce au-dessus du même et monsieur
Legault propose c'est de continuer à
privatiser plus nous ce qu'on veut c'est
réglé enfin les problèmes de notre
système public puis on a dans notre
équipe Melissa généreux le docteur Yves
Bonnier la docteur Isabelle Leblanc 3
personnes qui demain matin pourraient
être ministre de la santé parce qu'ils
connaissent la réalité du terrain c'est
pas des gestionnaires c'est du monde du
terrain qui fait l'appliquer les
solutions qui viennent du terrain je
pense que c'est par là qu'il faut
commencer en santé au Québec c'est
socialiste fonctionnait en matière de
santé monsieur le 12 bois on le saurait
ça fait 40 ans qu'on a des ministres de
la Santé qui se promène avec des
structures puis qui changent toutes les
structures et pourtant jamais on a eu
des problèmes jamais on a eu un système
aussi inefficace que celui qu'on a à
l'heure actuelle moi je pense monsieur
Nadou Dubois il faut amener là on peut
bien jouer encore des structures une
autre fois ou deux autres fois mais la
réalité c'est que ça prend de la
concurrence vous le savez comme moi un
monopole peu importe même si le public
ou privé un monopole ça ne fonctionne
pas puis au Québec malheureusement c'est
les patients du Québec qui payent
présentement pour ce monopole inefficace
il faut emmener avec dépendre il faut
prendre
vous savez que pour les choses
essentielles je vous donne un exemple
bien concret un médecin présentement
Québec là il ne peut pas pratiquer et au
public et au privé c'est illégal c'est
100 % un ou 100 % 0 au Québec on a un
système à deux vitesses présentement
nous on veut un système à une vitesse
parce que présentement les autres riches
peuvent y aller mais nous on veut que
tout le monde puisse avoir accès au
système de santé privé
bon il manque 6 milliards de dollars par
année en santé au Québec François
Legault avec son fédéralisme de gain
dans le Canada nous avait promis d'aller
les chercher il a demandé par quatre
fois puis maintenant Justin Trudeau se
déplace même pas il prend même plus la
peine il répond à 24 heures non donc
s'il manque 6 milliards ce sont des
sommes importantes et notre relation
avec le fédéral elle doit être nommée si
on décidait nous-mêmes de nos budgets
qu'on prenait nos propres décisions
comme québécoise et québécois on serait
pas pris à quémander comme toutes les
provinces canadiennes des sommes aussi
majeurs que 6 milliards de dollars la
seule solution à ça c'est l'indépendance
du Québec
on va laisser votre choix pour vous
autres mais maintenant le privé
quel est votre choix
puis on a pas mal plus de chance d'y
arriver que de faire référendum sur les
indépendants
le privé en santé nous on propose plus
de privé mais du privé gratuit
ça va permettre d'innover et moi
j'aimerais ça poser une question
monsieur Nadaud Dubois là les dizaines
de milliers de personnes qui sont faites
opérer pendant pandémie au privé
gratuitement qu'est-ce que vous leur
dites que tu as pas une bonne idée parce
que c'est pas votre idéologie qu'est-ce
que vous leur dites à ces personnes-là
qui ont été satisfaites qui ont rien
payé c'est le goût vous le savez là que
dans un contexte d'urgence dans un
contexte de crise sanitaire sans
précédent on était d'accord d'avoir un
recours temporaire et limité au privé
sur le coup il y avait des gens qui
mourraient plein maintenant il y avait
du monde qui mourrait plein d'hôpitaux
mais est-ce que l'avenir de notre
système c'est de se rapprocher d'un
modèle privé ou est-ce que l'avenir de
notre système c'est de reconstruire
notre système public c'est là qu'on va
les violences de vision
erreur là vous promettez encore ce que
d'autres chefs en premier avant vous
c'est à dire un médecin de famille par
québécois
vraiment est-ce que est-ce qu'on peut
croire à ça compte tenu de l'échec
continue depuis 20 ans je comprends les
sceptiques mais on n'a pas le droit de
laisser tomber plus d'un million de
Québécois on va se rendre à combien un
point 5 millions 2 millions de Québécois
qui ont pas accès à un médecin de
famille pourquoi est-ce que ailleurs
dans le monde sont capables de le faire
puis nous au Québec on serait pas
capable de le faire il s'agit d'aller
recruter davantage de médecins d'aller
recruter davantage d'infirmières d'aller
recruter davantage de PAB mais aussi de
revoir l'organisation du travail ce soir
là j'aimerais vraiment m'adresser là à
tous les professionnels de la santé là
qui font du temps supplémentaire
obligatoire il faut changer les
conditions de travail puis faire en
sorte qu'on élimine ce temps
supplémentaire obligatoire je pense à
toutes ces femmes toutes ces merdes de
famille qui sont pas capables d'aller
chercher leurs enfants l'après-midi
parce qu'elle se disent ah bah
finalement peut-être que je vais être
obligé de rester puis elle rentre à la
maison puis elles ont manqué un
événement important avec leur enfant
c'est équilibre famille travaille ne
jamais être à la bonne place de ne
jamais être une bonne mère ou ne jamais
se sentir que tu étais pas une bonne
mère que c'est peut-être sent n'était
pas une bonne employée ça ça doit
arrêter c'est pour ça qu'on doit mettre
entre autres faim autant supplémentaire
obligatoire mais c'est aussi pour ça
qu'on doit faire en sorte que on a des
des ratios de patients par rapport au
nombre de professionnels qu'on a qui
sont la proposer depuis deux ans
supplémentaire obligatoire ça revient
effectivement beaucoup quand on se
promène dans les établissements c'est
possible ou non le tour de table rapide
est-ce qu'on peut arrêter ça monsieur le
groupe
plus d'infirmières ça prend plus
d'infirmières ça prend trois ans former
des infirmières qu'est-ce qu'on a fait
on a mis des incitatifs pour en ramener
de la retraite on a mis des incitatifs
pour les étudiants qui étudient en
sciences mais un moment donné il y a
personne ici peut faire de la magie mais
c'est pas vrai c'est qu'on a mis
l'argent dans des agences privées qui
ont pris les infirmières du public
qu'ils ont mis au public au privé ça
coûte une fortune un milliard au lieu de
200 millions c'est ça le plan de la CAQ
et les conditions de travail au public
pendant ce temps-là ce sont détériorés
donc faut fermer les agences mettre fin
à l'usage des privé et rehausser
substantiellement les conditions de
travail en même temps ce que la CAQ n'a
pas le courage de faire
le problème bien sûr c'est de qu'il faut
ramener nos infirmières puis toutes nos
soignants dans le système public mais
sous la gouverne de monsieur Legault
c'est pas juste qu'on en a pas ramené
c'est qu'ils ont continué à s'en aller
aux chutes Québec l'an passé c'est 478
d'émissions dans toute l'année cette
année en janvier puis juin c'est 526 des
missions enfin que le monde il continue
à s'en aller du système pourquoi parce
qu'on les traite pas bien et c'est ça
qu'il faut régler sur le temps
supplémentaire obligatoire
c'est évidemment il y a personne qui
souhaiterait ça il y a personne qui
voudrait vivre ces conditions-là c'est
vrai que les infirmières s'en vont mais
la solution c'est pas d'abolir les
agences privées par la suite ça va être
encore pire il va encore plus de pénurie
les filles ne veulent plus travailler
dans un avec pour un aussi mauvaise
employeur que le gouvernement du Québec
d'où l'importance d'avoir une
concurrence des employeurs tu vas
pouvoir offrir des conditions de travail
décentes à ces filles très bien on vous
entendu là-dessus sujet extrêmement
important aussi les soins à domicile là
il y a des différences fondamentales
entre vous il y a 48 000 personnes qui
attendent des soins à domicile
actuellement est-ce qu'on a les moyens
de les aider puis en même temps
payer 800 000 dollars par chambre
monsieur Legault dans des maisons
d'années magnifiques par ailleurs
débat que j'ouvre là-dessus mais est-ce
que les soins domicile il faudrait pas
en faire beaucoup plus qu'on peut pas
tout faire en même temps sur le bout en
2018 on avait promis d'ajouter 800
millions en soins et services à domicile
on a ajouté deux milliards OK et on a le
même problème qu'on vient de discuter ça
prend des infirmières ça prend le temps
des former les infirmières maintenant
quand j'entends certains médecins en
opposition avec des maisons des années
ben voyons donc besoin des deux quand
une personne les moyens pour les deux
stops
il y a des personnes qui sont plus
autonomes puis ont besoin d'aller dans
une Maison des Aînés on doit ça à nos
aînés on avait un texte ce matin sur
Radio-Canada qui montrait que la
rénovation des CHSLD à Montréal était
retardé parce que ça coûte trop cher
est-ce qu'il y a pas la réalité de
l'argent
il y a aussi la question de trouver
travailleurs de la construction
rapidement
c'est pour ça quand monsieur Nadau du
bois dit il va mettre 74 milliards dans
le transport collectif mais il va te
faire arrêter de bâtir les hôpitaux des
écoles on ne sait pas
la meilleure la meilleure maison pour
les aînés puis je mettrai ça tous les
aînés du Québec c'est la vôtre c'est
s'il y a un message s'il y a un message
qui a été entendu partout que j'ai
entendu partout dans toutes mes tournées
c'est ce message là c'est pour ça merci
merci à vous de le reconnaître puis
c'est pour ça qu'on a besoin d'avoir une
allocation aînée de 2000 dollars
parrainés non imposable qui arrive année
après année qui fait en sorte que c'est
pas un crédit d'impôt là c'est pas
quelque chose de de non réel c'est de
l'argent dans vos poches qui arrivent
année après année de la même manière
qu'au Québec collectivement on s'est dit
on a besoin d'avoir une allocation
famille qu'on est alors donc le
corollaire puis je vous pose la question
monsieur Lego dit on peut faire les deux
est-ce que vous laissez tomber les
maisons pour aînées se programme là on
finit ce qu'on a à finir mais on doit
investir de manière important dans les
soins à domicile et donner les moyens
aux aînés de pouvoir dans certaines
maisons qui ont commencé on veut les
terminer mais en poursuit pas ça parce
qu'il faut s'investir dans les soins à
domicile
les aînés sont une richesse pour notre
société il va falloir commencer à le
dire puis agir en conséquence et donc
les écouter ils veulent des soins à
domicile ils veulent vieillir à la
maison et ça a donne que c'est un modèle
pas mal moins coûteux que les maisons
des aînés à un million de dollars par
chambre ce modèle-là qui est dépassé il
n'est pas viable financièrement et il
isole des gens qui voudraient rester
plus longtemps possible à la maison
c'est pour ça que nous on a on s'est
engagés financièrement à tripler l'offre
de soins à domicile et que on va se
préoccuper également des chsfd parce que
c'est facile couper un ruban puis
prendre des photos devant une maison des
années mais pendant ce temps-là la
qualité de la nourriture la
climatisation la qualité du bâtiment
dans les CHSLD soit on n'a pas fait
grand chose donc à un moment donné il
faut être transparent et cohérent dans
la dignité quelques années ça devrait
pas être négociable dans notre société
moi j'accepte pas que la génération qui
a construit le Québec en ce moment elle
est part de vieillir parce qu'elle a
peur à cause de ce qu'elle a vu dans les
CHSLD et la solution la plupart des gens
sur le plateau ici ce soir s'entendre
c'est un grand virage national vers les
soins à domicile il faut finir les
chantiers qui ont été commencés mais la
priorité ensuite c'est quoi les soins à
domicile permettent aux aînés du Québec
de vieillir à la maison et aussi rénover
les CHSLD existant parce que c'est là
qu'il faut commencer les hommes et les
femmes qui vivent dans ces institutions
là vivent pas bien ils vivent pas dans
dignité puis moi j'accepte pas ça faut
investir dans nos CHSLD tout en prenant
le virage vers les soins à domicile
évidemment que des chambres à un million
de dollars on n'aura pas les moyens d'en
payer à tout le monde monsieur Legault
c'est très bien je comprends que c'est
effectivement ça paraît bien
politiquement pour les chanceux de la
loterie des maisons des années mais
malheureusement c'est pas viable pour
l'ensemble de la population je pense
qu'on a une espèce de consensus ici là
puis c'est vrai on connaît mais on le
vit quelques nos grands-parents les
années là les garder le plus longtemps
possible à la maison je pense que c'est
la meilleure chose la chose la plus
souhaitable autant pour les années que
pour les familles qui voulaient les
visiter c'est pour ça qu'on veut oui on
va investir évidemment dans les soins à
domicile mais il y a aussi la question
des aidants naturels ou également où il
va falloir investir davantage parce que
eux aussi ont un rôle primordial à jouer
si on veut lui maintenant maintenir nos
années le plus longtemps possible à la
maison les gens les gens ont vu voient
les différences de programmes on est là
pour ça la santé mentale je ne peux pas
ne pas vous parler de santé mentale il y
avait des demandes pour que des
psychologues du privé soient transférés
au public pendant la pandémie les
adolescents entre autres qui appelaient
le
CLSI qu'on disait un an un an et demi
d'attente bon on fait quoi là vous
faites quoi en matière de santé mentale
depuis là-dessus là je pense que c'est
important puis on voit on commence à
voir mesurer l'impact ce qui s'est passé
ces dernières années on a vu que ça la
santé mentale des Québécois étaient
durement affectés particulièrement les
plus jeunes on voit même une étude
maintenant de l'Université de Sherbrooke
qui nous apprend qu'elle a détresse
psychologique la dépression est rendu à
50% chez les jeunes je pense qu'on fait
quoi on propose un sommet dans les 100
premiers jours puis d'ailleurs je tends
la mets aux autres parties j'aimerais
aussi que ça se fait ça donne une façon
non partisanes parce que le sujet trop
important pour commencer à faire de la
politique avec ça faire un sommet parce
qu'on y arrive pas je savais que les
effectifs très bien il va falloir
politique
mais la santé mentale ça devrait pas
être un tabou premièrement ça devrait
pas non plus être luxe puis notre
système de santé publique devrait
traiter seul à santé mentale sur un pied
d'égalité avec la santé physique ça ça
veut dire investir massivement pour
rapatrier les psychologues qui ont
quitté le système public dans le système
que vous voulez ramener au plus au
public avec les salaires du privé
bonifiant leur salaire en bonifiant là
on améliorant leur autonomie
professionnelle il faut que ce soit
aussi simple se faire traiter pour la
santé mentale que se faire traiter pour
un bras cassé dans notre système de
santé publique vous opinez d'accord avec
ce que Monsieur Nadaud Dubois vient de
dire et j'ajouterai que non seulement
faut rapatrier dans le système public
des psychologues disponible mais quand
je vous parle d'un CLSC renforcé c'est
toutes sortes de professionnels qui sont
là pour offrir en prévention un soin ou
une intervention avant que d'autres
choses de plus graves se produisent donc
il faut penser aussi à la prévention
parce que c'est moins coûteux c'est plus
intelligent mais surtout c'est plus
humain d'avoir des ressources en
prévention que de guérir madame anglais
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour faire face à
ces demandes de consultation
en santé mentale vous allez d'abord
permettre de dire que c'est un sujet qui
me touche personnellement beaucoup parce
que je sais c'est quoi être une petite
fille de 10 ans puis de se lever le
matin puis de te dire que si tu fais pas
ton linge puis le linge de ta petite
sœur il y en aura pas de lunch parce que
ta mère est pas capable de passer à
travers ces enjeux de santé mentale puis
ça c'est mon histoire personnelle mais
c'est l'histoire de milliers de
québécois il y a 10 ans il y a 20 ans
maintenant aujourd'hui on ne peut plus
considérer la santé mentale comme étant
un sujet parmi tant d'autres on doit
avoir un accès universel pour des soins
de psychothérapie c'est ce qu'on propose
que vous alliez dans le privé que vous
alliez dans le public vous pouvez
utiliser votre carte de la RAMQ pour
obtenir des soins c'est ça dont on a
besoin aujourd'hui au Québec en 2022
psychologues qui sont au public pour
être compétitif avec le privé mais je
veux quand même répliquer à ce que
Monsieur dum me dit tantôt à propos des
deux dernières années parce que Monsieur
dum durant deux ans il a joué le rôle
d'un agitateur là qui a profité de la
souffrance des gens au Québec ils
pensent que c'est pas vrai qu'il y a eu
moins de décès au Québec
franchement là c'est irresponsable goût
la façon dont agit monsieur
québécois
tout ce que vous toujours tomber
là-dedans là vous êtes pas capable
d'admettre qu'il y a un problème de
santé mentale de près d'admettre que il
y a eu des impacts vous n'êtes pas
capable d'admettre que c'est les enfants
du Québec qui souffrent à cause de vos
discussions est-ce que vous êtes au
Québec non monsieur le gombo
monsieur Lego on a plus de 1000 Canada
on ne peut sacrifier deux fois plus
d'années monsieur
vous avez été responsable avec les
enfants du Québec monsieur Lego
n'oubliez jamais ça
très bien ça met fin à ce thème de la
santé prochaine thème éducation et
service aux citoyens
valoriser l'éducation c'est l'avenir du
Québec c'est l'avenir de nos enfants il
y a beaucoup d'endroits défavorisants à
Montréal remettre en face sur
l'éducation ça pourrait aider beaucoup à
ces gens-là à sortir de certains
problèmes beaucoup de personnes de
difficultés à trouver des places en
garderie que c'est un enjeu assez
problématique et très difficile d'avoir
une place en garderie là il y a des
années d'attente question chef Matteo
la clé ça va être les conditions des
éducatrices autant au milieu familiaux
quand c'était parce que pas d'éducatrice
pas de place les écoles publiques ça
m'arrache le cœur de voir dans quel état
beaucoup de ces écoles se trouvent
que beaucoup aussi manque de personnel
on manque d'enseignants dans les écoles
vous êtes enseignants vous voyez des
gens partir oui il y a beaucoup de gens
qui partent c'est soufflant il y a des
questionnements à savoir est-ce que je
vais être capable de faire 20 ans dans
la profession ce serait quoi les moyens
concrets mis en place pour garder les
enseignants dans la profession
j'ai rencontré Noémie Dumas dans une
école de Rosemont je suis entré dans
l'école il y avait plein d'enseignants
physiciens qui ont une question pour les
chefs et les descendue en bas puis j'ai
été frappé elle m'a dit ça fait deux ans
que j'enseigne et je songe déjà
peut-être à quitter
parce que la charge de travail parce que
l'aide insuffisante la difficulté les
élèves dans les classes normales la
question puis vous avez 35 secondes pour
y répondre madame anglaise vous êtes la
première comment faire pour convaincre
les Noémie Dumas de ce monde de rester
dans les salles de classe
mais j'entends le message de Noémie puis
j'ai rencontré Sarah il y a deux jours
puis Sarah me disait qu'après 4 ans elle
avait décidé de quitter la profession
d'enseignement parce qu'elle était plus
capable parce qu'elle vivait un burn out
personnel était plus capable de faire
face à la musique parce que ils n'ont
pas suffisamment de ressources il y a
des classes qui sont bondées ici tu as 8
personnes qui souffrent par exemple d'un
TDAH ou qui ont besoin d'aide ils n'ont
pas les ressources nécessaires ce qu'il
faut c'est aller recruter pour trouver
des ressources pour soutenir nos
enseignants dans un premier temps puis
faire en sorte qu'on valorise
véritablement la profession j'ai été
élevé par deux profs d'éducation pour
moi c'est fondamentale Gabriel Nadaud
Dubois 35 secondes ça fait 10 ans que je
me bats pour l'éducation c'est une des
valeurs qui est extrêmement
importante pour moi puis on réglera pas
les problèmes de notre système
d'éducation si on n'arrête pas c'est
exode là dont vous venez de parler des
profs et de l'ensemble des
professionnels qui quittent ce que les
enseignants enseignants nous disent
qu'on les rencontre je rencontre pas mal
c'est qu'ils ont besoin de renforts ils
ont besoin de professionnels qui
viennent les aider parce qu'il y a
quelques années il y avait trois quatre
élèves en difficulté dans une classe
maintenant il y en a 10 il y en a 15 les
enseignantes sont plus capables
d'enseigner faut leur ramener du renfort
c'est la priorité en éducation monsieur
Legault 35 secondes
l'éducation ça a toujours été ma
priorité puis ça sera toujours ma
priorité tout ce que j'ai dans vie c'est
à cause de l'éducation dans quatre
dernières années on a augmenté le budget
de l'éducation de
26%. on a augmenté salaire des
enseignants de
15%. il y avait pas beaucoup d'appui
chez mes amis le quand je disais je veux
des négociations différenciées avec les
syndicats donc il faut valoriser la
profession d'enseignants ça prend quatre
ans avant de former un enseignant on a
mis des bonnets pour ceux qui vont
étudier en éducation donc faut continuer
Eric duen 35 secondes mais c'est
évidemment que la première chose c'est
de valoriser les enseignants développer
le sentiment d'identité à l'école on a
parlé tout à l'heure de la santé c'est
un peu malheureusement le même problème
qu'on retrouve en éducation souvent ces
gens-là l'impression d'être des espèces
de pions dans un système ultra
centralisé ultra bureaucratisé avec
plein de monde au-dessus de leur tête
ils ont pas l'impression d'être un
humain qui a une marge de manœuvre que
le lien avec les parents il faut
décentraliser tout ça ça a un impact
direct sur le travail de l'enseignant au
quotidien ça lui permet d'avoir une
marge de manœuvre d'avoir ses propres
projets avec ses enfants et c'est ça
qu'il faut valoriser dans le Québec de
demain merci Paul Saint-Pierre plat
Mondon conclusion mais moi je suis très
heureux d'entendre que tout le monde
veut revaloriser le rôle du professeur
donc j'invite tout le monde à être
cohérent et travaillons avec les
professeurs à trouver les solutions
lorsqu'on écoute il nous disent nous on
est là pour la mission de l'enseignement
donnez-nous les ressources
d'accompagnement psychologue
orthopédagogue pour qu'on puisse avoir
le nombre de personnes pour atteindre
notre mission ils sont là pour de bonnes
raisons des horaires plus flexibles on a
fait une sortie également sur les écoles
Vitus j'ai dit au premier débat monsieur
Lego que sous sa gouverne s'est passé de
50 % à 59% des cases il a dit il faut
mais après vérification c'est vrai c'est
en mariage des bovins et je termine en
disant que en écoutant les professeurs
ont revalorise et on trouve des
solutions vraisemblablement ce qui a pas
été fait dans les quatre dernières
années Noémie Dumas avait déjà elle
intuitionnait si je peux dire la réponse
des salaires puis dit oui c'est bien que
les salaires a augmenté évidemment on
peut pas être contre ça mais elle a dit
c'est le vrai problème est ailleurs
elle nous a touché petite suite avec
elle c'est très court
mais je pense pas que c'est une question
nécessairement de salaire c'est aussi
savoir c'est quoi les outils qui
pourraient nous a donné pour aider
concrètement les élèves dans le besoin
parce qu'on est de la difficulté à avoir
du soutien en classe
je le répète la fête deux ans qui
travaille dans les écoles peut être plus
clair elle me disait je sais pas si je
vais arriver jusqu'à ma cinquième année
vous commencez le débat ouvert monsieur
Dumas c'est très émouvant quand on
entend des enseignants comme ça parce
que c'est une richesse on en a besoin
des filles comme elles en centimes vous
savez que la rentrée scolaire il manque
encore des profs le gouvernement a été
obligé de faire ce même les chauffeurs
d'autobus il y a Marseille une rentrée
scolaire très difficile pour plusieurs
parents du Québec moi je pense qu'il
faut oui il faut mettre des ressources
oui ça prend de l'aide oui il y a des il
y a des enfants qui ont besoin aussi
d'un cheminement particulier donc il
faut diversifier l'offre il faut
impliquer le parent également au cœur
parce que souvent on oublie le parent
pareil comme c'était juste la
bureaucratie qui devait décider pour
nous c'est très important parce que
conservateur que le parent soit au cœur
des décisions monsieur Hugo je vais vous
donner un droit de parole parce que
comme c'est le premier ministre vous
parlez avoir en disant oui c'est bien
beau les salaires mais j'ai besoin
d'aide j'ai besoin d'aide dans la classe
parce que et je regarde depuis 4 ans
depuis qu'on est là on rajouter 2000
orthophonistes orthopédagogue et
professionnel pour les enfants qui ont
des difficultés d'apprentissage parce
que d'abord de ses enfants là il y en a
25 pour cent deux autres qui vont
décrocher éventuellement donc il faut
continuer ça prend 4 ans pour former des
orthophonistes des orthopédagogues on
est en train de le faire mais encore une
fois on peut pas faire de magie les 2000
qu'on pouvait embaucher on les embaucher
quand on va être capable d'en faire plus
on va en faire plus monsieur c'est
incroyable quand même parce que je viens
de parler de donner du renfort c'est
exactement ce que Noémie du maudit on a
besoin de renfort dans nos classes et
l'argent s'achète pas tout dans la vie
ces femmes là se sont en grande majorité
des femmes veulent des meilleurs
conditions de travail il y a un seul
parti politique ici sur cette scène qui
a prévu dans son corps de financier des
sommes réservées pour une bonification
générale des conditions de travail dans
l'ensemble des services publics y
compris en éducation
vous avez dans votre programme ça m'a
surpris un peu vous dites les
fonctionnaires qui vont perdre leur
emploi on va les envoyer dans les écoles
puis ils vont enseigner c'est pas dans
notre programme mais effectivement mais
c'est dire qu'il faut valoriser la
profession d'enseignement si on est
capable de récupérer des gens il faut
aussi rien de dévalorisant pour
quelqu'un de descendre d'une tour puis
descendre dans une classe bah
l'enseigner on a besoin d'enseignants on
va une pénurie déjà de la pénurie va
s'accentuer dans les années à venir on
le sait déjà monsieur Roy je spécifique
le Parti québécois c'est également
engagé à réinvestir dans le réseau
public d'éducation à tous les niveaux je
veux toucher un mot sur
l'alphabétisation également et la langue
française le niveau qu'on a de langue
française on a lancé on a proposé un
vaste chantier ou que ce soit à l'âge
adulte ou plus jeune lorsque des
difficultés d'apprentissage de la langue
française
se donner le défi de réduire
l'analphabétisme et on a proposé des
mesures en fonction de cet objectif-là
c'est un sujet trop souvent tabou et je
pense que si on nomme on aime notre
langue française il faut se donner cet
objectif-là et les moyens qui vont avec
parce que du chemin à faire
effectivement ça des impacts à tous les
niveaux l'estime de soi l'économie mais
surtout c'est notre langue française je
veux donner un prix aux parents des
milliers de parents qui ont organisé une
chaîne de courriel j'ai été inondé
depuis deux semaines vous aussi
j'imagine sur le problème des écoles à
trois vitesses je veux dire ce qu'on
entend et je pense que ça vaut la peine
privé des cheminements particuliers dans
les écoles publiques soit qu'on paye ou
qu'on paye pas mais les bons élèves vont
là et il reste les classes ordinaires
beaucoup d'élèves en difficulté ce qu'on
appelle le système à trois vitesses
qu'est-ce qu'on fait vous avez des
positions différentes là-dessus madame
anglais est-ce qu'on change
la première chose que j'aimerais faire
c'est m'adresser à tous les adoles tous
les ados qui écoutent qui nous écoutent
ce soir puis tous les parents des ados
moi je sais là que j'en ai un à la
maison qui a 15 ans puis c'est difficile
de le réveiller à 6h du matin à moins
que ce soit pour aller faire une
pratique de football la réalité là c'est
que aujourd'hui pour accrocher nos
jeunes il faut qu'elle ait aussi des
programmes de science études d'art
études de sport études puis nous ce
qu'on propose c'est que c'est programme
là dans notre école publique soit
gratuit et que ce soit ça dépendent pas
du portefeuille de tes parents pour que
tu puisses participer à ça il y en a
déjà des centaines de milliers qui
participent 200 000 élèves qui
participent à ça mais ça c'est un moyen
de raccrocher nos jeunes puis de faire
en sorte qu'il en profite et ça ça
contribue à faire en sorte que l'école
publique soit réellement publique bon
quelqu'un là dessus qu'est-ce qu'on fait
avec ça monsieur ce que j'ai envie de
rappeler à tout le monde qui nous écoute
ce soir c'est que ce problème là de
l'inégalité des chances entre les
enfants du Québec c'est un le problème
qu'il faut le régler c'est vous qui a
60% des jeunes qui peuvent par une école
privée vont à l'université 60%. les
jeunes dans les classes publiques
régulières c'est 15%
. ça veut dire là que si vous ne laissez
pas dans le bon cas vous vous abonnez
les écoles privées ou dans une ou dans
bonne famille vous avez moins de chance
de réussir votre vie puis moi j'accepte
pas ça faut que nos écoles publiques au
Québec donnent les mêmes chances à tout
le monde c'est une question d'égalité en
tous les petits gars toutes les petites
filles du Québec fais quoi avec ça on
garde seulement c'est d'améliorer nos
écoles publiques puis on avait promis en
2018 d'ajouter une heure par jour ça
c'est 5 heures par semaine dans toutes
les écoles secondaires pour faire trois
choses plus de sport plus d'activités
artistiques plus d'aide aux devoirs
savez-vous quoi on le fait donc ça
faisait des autobus jaunes là maintenant
une heure plus tard les jeunes qui sont
dans nos écoles publiques et en plus de
sport plus d'or plus d'aide aux devoirs
faut continuer dans cette direction mais
on garde les entre guillemets les trois
vitesses vous vous dites on rend gratuit
les programmes particuliers absolument
et Québec Solidaire a le Parti québécois
vous dites l'école privée
ultimement c'est terminé c'est à dire
qu'il faut rééquilibrer le financement
parce que là on accélère la part du
privé et c'est vraiment trop à vitesse
c'est la troisième vitesse créer des
environnements d'apprentissage ou les
écoles sont vétustes monsieur Legault
c'est un fait 59 % des environnements ou
il y a trop de cas nécessitant un
soutien spécifique dans la classe les
ratios sont trop grands donc il y a une
question d'équité pour le public
là-dedans ou est-ce qu'il faut
rééquilibrer à la faveur du réseau
public pour bien chancellal pour tous
les enfants
il faut également peut-être ajouter
quelque chose quand même parce que moi
ça va m'avait beaucoup marqué quand mes
enfants sont rentrés à l'école les
effets scolaires qui soient gratuits
puis quand on va sur le service de garde
sur l'or du linge c'est pas normal que
les parents aient à payer 800 dollars
par année juste pour avoir son enfant
qui est un lunch à chaque jour à l'école
publique ce n'est pas normal ça ça
devrait être assumé par l'État et ça
c'est ce qu'on propose également c'est
comme ça qu'on va rendre l'école
publique réellement
parce que ça c'est vrai que c'est un
vrai problème là même nos écoles
publiques primaires et secondaires sont
même plus gratuite il y a de plus en
plus de frais et monsieur Legault a pas
réglé ce problème là les frais
continuent de se multiplier dans nos
écoles publiques publiques
nous on va réduire cette facture là la
facture de la gratuité scolaire puis on
parle économie là qui peuvent aller
jusqu'à 600 dollars par année par
famille ça c'est une urgence nationale
au Québec que nos écoles publiques
redeviennent rapidement faut pas acheter
le bébé avec l'eau du bain le les écoles
privées ont un bénéfice extraordinaire
sur la société québécoise d'abord ça
coûte moins cher à l'ensemble des
contribuables pour le rappeler que les
écoles publiques pour chaque élève puis
l'autre à faire c'est que ça a permis
une concurrence on ne veut pas
reproduire avec l'éducation ce qu'on a
en santé qu'un monopole inefficace tout
centralisé bureaucratisé monsieur
Legault en 2018 au débat des chefs
avaient dit j'avais demandé à la toute
fin est-ce que vous mettez votre siège
en jeu sur un sujet vous avez dit
maternelle 4 ans vous en souvenez
évidemment vous en aviez promis 5 il y
en a 1610 je crois est-ce qu'on continue
où on arrête là j'aimerais d'abord
le nombre de classes de maternelles 4
ans il y a des parties ici qui sont cons
parce qu'ils défendent les CPE ils
voient ça comme en opposition nous on
offre le choix au parent c'est quoi
l'avantage entre autres des maternelles
4 ans c'est que c'est des écoles
primaires où il y a plus
d'orthophonistes pour les autres années
donc on veut continuer ça marche dans
beaucoup de pays mais là il y a des
parties ici là qui sont contre les
maternelles 4 ans je comprends pas ça
juste que quand on gouverne faut
prioriser et vous vous avez mis la
au plancher pour les maternelles
4 ans ça il est commissions scolaires
c'était vos grandes priorités pour les
familles et pendant ce temps-là la liste
d'attente dans les CPA augmentaient et
leur augmenter sous votre gouverne elle
a augmenté chaque place qui manque mais
potentiellement c'est une femme qui va
vous
aidera à la maison des années ce qu'on
ouvre quelques maternelles 4 ans puis
pendant ce temps-là les garderies
ferment puis les parents et les enfants
par dizaines de milliers on était rendu
à 50 000 enfants s'en placent en
garderie et là Monsieur Leroux lui donne
des chiffres pourquoi vous sur ces
maternelles 4 ans
on est pour votre présence d'un pays
scandinave vous les connaissez bien
pourquoi vous êtes contre les
maternelles si je peux répondre s'il
vous plaît c'est pas une question de
manière quatre ans c'est la question de
garantir à chaque parent et à chaque
enfant une place en garderie et vous
vous insistez sur vos maternelles 4 ans
et pendant ce temps-là tout le reste et
à l'abandon
donc ils sont d'accord des dizaines de
milliers d'enfants qui ont pas de place
nous on propose une place garantie en
CPA comme à l'école primaire c'est aussi
simple que ça monsieur Lego sous votre
gouverne il y a eu un calcul pour les
femmes un recul important non mais c'est
pas une blague vous dites oh c'est pas
une blague
merci merci un recul pour les femmes
pourquoi parce qu'on a des femmes mais
non mais c'est sérieux c'est sérieux il
y a des femmes aujourd'hui qui ne
peuvent pas retourner sur le marché du
travail parce qu'elles n'ont pas de
service de garde elles n'ont pas accès
elles veulent le faire mais ils sont pas
capables de le faire parce que toutes
les attentes ça les attentes et là
augmenter ce qu'on doit faire au Québec
il y a eu une révolution quand on a fait
une petite révolution importante au
Québec quand on a fait les CPE c'était
sous avec Pauline Marois mais il faut il
faut le souligner aujourd'hui on doit
aller ailleurs il faut que les services
de garde soient rendus un droit ça veut
dire que quand on a un enfant et que on
souhaite travailler on a l'état est
l'obligation de fournir un service de
garde de la même manière qu'on a droit à
l'éducation ça nous viendrait pas à
l'idée d'avoir un enfant qui a 7 ans qui
rentre à l'école puis on lui dit oh non
vous allez attendre deux ans parce qu'on
pas de place c'est la même logique qui
devrait s'appliquer pour les services de
garde et faire en sorte que ce soit un
droit ça c'est la proposition du parti
libérale avec 8 et 70 pour tout le monde
à travers tout le territoire peu importe
le service où vous allez c'est ça que
vous allez sur cette question là on
reste sur cette question est-ce qu'on
devrait oui oui ce qu'on doit réaliser
oui écouter
cette phrase là mais on augmente les
salaires mais que les femmes on les a
pas traités équitablement c'est
contraire on a augmenté le salaire des
enseignants des éducatrices en fait des
préposés de 15%. puis les garderies là
quand vous avez quitté le pouvoir en
2018 il y en avait autant qu'aujourd'hui
de place manquantes vous aviez créé une
histoire de maison de fou il y avait 12
étapes à cause de Tony Tomassi il y
avait 12 étapes avant d'ouvrir une place
en garde de riz c'est pas crédible on
voit les femmes qui sont sortis qui ont
manifesté qui ont dit moi j'ai rencontré
des femmes qui ont dit il y a des
non monsieur Legault ça s'est détérioré
puis cet enjeu là il est important parce
que vous savez quoi en terme d'emploi on
veut avoir des personnes qui soient
épanouies puis qui retournent sur le
marché de l'emploi et ça fait partie des
solutions pour le Québec monsieur
rouelle en fait les deux ont raison
c'est que c'est à dire que autant les
libéraux que laque sous leur leadership
ils nous ont toujours promis
qu'effectivement il y aurait plus
d'attendre pour les parents pour leurs
enfants CPE puis les deux ont donné un
bilan qui était totalement opposé ce
qu'ils avaient promis en campagne
électorale puis aujourd'hui l'ensemble
des partis politiques des autres partis
politiques proposent encore la même
affaire en disant on va régler le
problème des listes d'attentes mais il y
en a pas un qui leur règle pour nous la
solution c'est de donner un bon de garde
de 200$ par enfant par semaine aux
parents qui malheureusement n'ont pas
gagné à la loterie des CPE et qui sont
50 quelques milles à végéter sur des
listes d'attente depuis beaucoup trop
longtemps et comme ça on va pouvoir
éliminer le
programme des CPAS avec votre chèque que
vous envoyez ne risque-t-il pas de
tomber dans une oubliette c'est à dire
que les gens qui vont qui sont en CPE
qui sont satisfaits les parents vont
continuer à en CP on veut pas couper les
CP on veut pas enlever les CPE on veut
que les parents qui ont pas accès au CPE
puissent ou eux aussi avoir leur morceau
du gâteau aussi c'est des contribuables
aussi ils payent eux aussi ont droit
d'avoir une aide de l'État le problème
avec le plan de Monsieur dum c'est qu'il
veut donner 200 dollars par enfant mais
le place en CPE ça coûte à peu près 250
donc c'est même pas raccord sauf que ça
veut dire il y a une contribution du
parrain de 8 et 70 par semaine par jour
le modèle des CPE c'est faux ce serait
un recul épouvantable
par an ça donne exactement le même
montant que de parler le reconstruire
c'est un vecteur d'égalité entre les
hommes et les femmes faut croire dans ce
modèle là Paul des financer Paul
Saint-Pierre pour l'abandon je vous
donne 15 secondes pour conclure là
dessus ce qu'on se pose la question
est-ce que mon enfant va avoir le droit
d'aller à l'école primaire l'an prochain
non on finance une place pour chaque
enfant pas besoin d'aller à l'école
primaire nous c'est ce qu'on propose
pour les CPE tout début de GT c'est tout
ce que ça très bien prochain thème
français immigration et
identité
migration qui l'excès soit augmenter en
fait tu penses pas que ça nuit vraiment
à notre culture on a s'en sortira pas
sans l'immigration il y a pas personne
pour pour travailler
on va embaucher du monde de l'extérieur
alors qu'il y a du monde ici qui
n'arrive pas à travailler
des immigrants c'est sûr que il faut
leur donner la possibilité de pouvoir se
loger
des proches aussi qui sont limitation et
j'ai l'impression que les politiques
d'ici sont passées incitatives pour les
retenir au Québec
la loi 96 c'est pas en faveur de tout le
monde prenez des vagues me donner la
fierté d'être québécoise de parler
français alors que aujourd'hui il
parlait français c'est pas fort je crois
à la souveraineté du Québec
comment pensez-vous qu'on préfère une
meilleure job pour défendre le français
et en même temps il y a énormément
d'immigrations et comment on fait pour
inclure ces personnes-là et leur faire
sentir qu'il y a une place ici parce
c'est juste ça qui veulent
alors je vous repose la question de
Madame Sao comment protéger la langue
française l'encourager mais en même
temps ouvrir les bras à l'immigration
première réponse 35 secondes chacun
Gabriel ado Dubois tout à fait d'accord
avec
avec cette jeune femme ce qu'il faut
c'est pas seulement faire un débat de
chiffres sur l'immigration c'est
construire un nouveau modèle
d'immigration qui fait les deux qui
ouvrent les bras où on accueille plus de
gens au Québec et où on met sur la
régionalisation sur la francisation en
milieu de travail et où on donne la
piqûre de la culture québécoise aux
nouveaux arrivants aux nouvelles
arrivantes c'est ça la meilleure manière
d'inclure d'intégrer de donner le goût
du français c'est de faire découvrir
notre belle culture nationale c'est ce
qu'on propose à Québec solidaire un
nouveau modèle qui va marcher pour le
Québec puis pour les gens merci
Eric duenne 35 secondes une immigration
réussie c'est essentiellement deux
choses pour le nouvel arrivant c'est
d'abord un emploi de qualité et c'est
aussi s'intégrer à la majorité
francophone pour nous ce sont toutes les
gares de chiffres sur les seuils le
chiffre à la limite c'est pas le chiffre
qui est le plus indicateur le meilleur
indicateur c'est est-ce qu'on peut oui
ou non intégrer ces gens-là sur le
marché de l'emploi et les intégrer la
majorité francophone le rôle du
gouvernement c'est de s'assurer qu'ils
peuvent apprendre le français et qui
peuvent intégrer le marché de l'emploi
c'est tout simple que ça les guerres de
chiffres ça ne mènent absolument nulle
part ça ne fait que diviser les
Québécois merci Dominique Anglade ben
écoutez d'abord moi je suis d'immigrants
qui sont venus s'installer en 69 ici au
Québec et il y en a ma mère est devenue
prof de français mon père était prof
également et on est capable d'intégrer
les immigrants en régionalisant
davantage en donnant des cours pour la
langue française en les encourageant en
promouvant en faisant la promotion de la
langue française on est capable de le
faire mais on doit arrêter aussi de
pointer du doigt on doit arrêter de
diviser on doit arrêter de dire que
l'immigration c'est un problème ou c'est
une menace
progressivement au Québec là on a de
grandes choses à accomplir on est
capable de faire avec tout le monde
merci Paul Saint-Pierre Plamondon je
pense qu'on doit discuter du modèle
d'immigration et juste pour que ce soit
clair lorsqu'on parle d'un modèle
d'immigration propre au Québec en
fonction de la spécificité linguistique
c'est pas du tout la même discussion que
les personnes parce que les personnes on
doit chercher à les accueillir les
intégrer leur donner toutes les
ressources pour que ce soit réussi
gagnant-gagnant pour tout le monde sur
la question du modèle faut pas non plus
tomber dans un tabou ou parler des
seuils tu deviendrais interdit parce que
c'est lié au déclin de la langue
française parce que le transfert
linguistique vers l'anglais des
allophones est trop importante donc
discutons-en de manière responsable pour
trouver le juste équilibre au niveau des
seuils merci monsieur Legault 35
secondes je te suis d'accord avec ce qui
vient des vrais débat c'est pas sur
l'immigration c'est sur notre capacité à
intégrer les nouveaux arrivants aux
Français et on a adopté le projet de loi
96 on augmente le pourcentage
d'immigrants qui parle français on a
doublé les cours de français pour les
nouveaux arrivants mais le premier
devoir du premier ministre du Québec
c'est d'assurer l'avenir du français
puis pour ça ben on a besoin
effectivement de limiter le nombre de
nouveaux arrivants qui parlent pas
français merci monsieur Legault débat
ouvert qui commence est-ce qu'il y a un
danger justement je reprends la balle au
bon d'accueillir trop d'immigrants
Dominique Anglet vous lancer donc ce
débat ouvert et trop c'est quoi à 70 80
90 comment vous voyez ça
au Québec aujourd'hui en 2022 là on a
accueilli 70 000 nouveaux arrivants
aujourd'hui donc on est capable de le
faire quand monsieur Legault nous parle
de la capacité d'accueil je sais pas sur
quoi il a calcule mais elle est on est
capable de faire aujourd'hui et on sait
très bien qu'on doit franciser davantage
qu'on doit régionaliser cette
immigration et on peut le faire sans
diviser les Québécois monsieur Legault
parle de son projet de loi 96 parle de
son projet de loi 21 mais la réalité
c'est qu'il a divisé les Québécois sur
ces deux enjeux-là on est capable de
s'unir là-dessus on est le seul parti le
seul parti ici à avoir voté contre le
projet de loi 96 et contre le projet de
loi 21 pour des questions de valeur
parce qu'il faut arrêter de penser que
on va protéger le français en enlevant
des droits on va le faire en faisant la
promotion et en faisant en encourageant
les gens à l'apprendre
monsieur Legault a dit par deux fois
dans la dernière semaine à 50 000
immigrants par année le français décline
quelle est sa réponse sa proposition au
québécoise de Québécois pour la suite
des choses continuons 50000 et c'est là
l'erreur 50000 c'est le chiffre qui a
été fixé par Jean Charrat au nom de la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre à l'époque
évidemment qui n'a jamais été réglé et
ce que monsieur Legault veut faire à
type de partie chef d'un parti
fédéraliste c'est de maintenir ses
seuils alors qu'il l'avoue très
ouvertement que à ce niveau là il y a un
déclin du français il y a un transfert
linguistique vers l'anglais nous on
demande que l'immigration économique
soit 100% francophone parce que ça
favorise l'intégration marché du travail
ça favorise la langue française et on
ramène à 35000 qui est le seuil des
années où le français progressait à
Montréal on veut également comme mes
collègues régionalisés on s'engage à ça
Mondon c'est que quand le Parti
québécois était au pouvoir sur les
immigrants choisis par le gouvernement
du Québec le gouvernement du PQ
acceptait qu'il y en ait seulement 50%
vous avez fait au début de votre mandat
et toutes les premières années de votre
manteau on est rendu à 80% à cause de la
pandémie à cause de la pandémie mais on
va continuer dans cette direction là en
utilisant plus la régionalisation les
étudiants mais il y a une différence là
de dire je suis un peu d'accord avec
vous que il faut pas aller comme Gabriel
nado Dubois et Madame Anglade à 70,80
milles moi je pense que 50 000 en
régionalisant en exigeant qui en a un
plus grand pourcentage qui parle
français je pense qu'on peut y arriver
moi je vous réponds monsieur Legault
c'est pas juste 50 000 c'est les 167000
les migrants temporaires c'est le chemin
Roxane et votre planification mène au
déclin le plus marqué de l'histoire du
Québec en français et vous savez que
votre loi 96 ne renverse pas ce
déclin-là vous l'avez dit deux fois que
50 000 cellier au déclin du français et
vous continuez dans les mêmes politiques
que Jean Charest et Philippe Couillard
et ça c'est pas responsable pour la
survie du des français en Amérique si
vous voulez seulement 35000 immigrants
qui est le modèle pas possible 50 000
donc sûrement pas possible 110 000
délibéraux puis 80000 de Québec
solidaire moi ce que je vous dis là
c'est que si on existe qui est nouveau
qui est un plus grand pourcentage qui
parle français avant d'arriver on va y
arriver c'est ça le pari qu'on fait très
bien prenez l'engagement que je vous
suggère temporaire mais ils sont
temporaires
ce discours là sur la baisse des seuils
d'immigration il est déconnecté de ce
qui se passe dans les régions du Québec
moi j'ai fait le tour des régions
derrière la semaine tout le monde nous
dit on a besoin de renfort on a besoin
de monde si on franchise bien si on
régionalise bien si on donne la piqûre
de la culture québécoise l'immigration
Québec ça peut fonctionner nous ce qu'on
dit là et c'est messieurs et Madame ont
des débats sur la capacité d'accueil du
Québec mais savez-vous que cette
capacité d'accueil là
jamais défini au Québec il y a des
démographes qui nous disent c'est 60 000
il y a des économies qui nous disent 80
000 nous on dit arrêtons si chicanne de
chez Flo donnons le mandat à un comité
d'experts de réfléchir cette question là
et de tracer la ligne en 60 et 80 000 ça
c'est une manière de sortir du débat de
chef parler du modèle d'immigration
Québec moi je pense ça peut marcher ça
peut être une richesse pour le Québec si
on a un bon système d'immigration qu'il
faut préciser que les récentes
statistiques de Statistiques Canada je
pense qu'elles sont elles ont inquiété
tout le monde peut-être un peu moins
libéraux mais à peu près tout le monde
au Québec je pense que c'est c'est très
inquiétant effectivement de voir un
recul du français cela étant dit faut
regarder pourquoi c'est pas les
francophones sont en train de s'être
similaire anglais je pense que tout le
monde a compris ça c'est pas la faute
des anglophones qui ont quand même des
droits historiques qui sont là qui ont
toujours été là tout le monde le dit
c'est véritablement la capacité de
franciser les immigrants de dire on va
doubler les immigrants c'est pas grave
on va on va les franciser au fur et à
mesure c'est sûr que faut faire
attention pour le problème il est
véritablement là les ressources
l'attention doit être mise là la
régionalisation c'est beau sans théorie
ça fait des années qu'on entend discours
là mais malheureusement puis on peut pas
reprocher ça aux émigrants il y a une
attirance naturelle pour Montréal à
montré on peut pas nier cette réalité là
Monsieur
promener en région j'ai écouté poser la
question sur la pénurie de logement dans
la plupart des régions du Québec si on
accueille 80000 personnes l'an prochain
est-ce que les logements vont par magie
être là donc on a une responsabilité
également d'équilibrer ça et 50000 si
vous êtes d'accord mais malheureusement
ce n'est pas un équilibre monsieur
Lebeau et vous le savez et vous avez nié
la crise du logement pendant 4 ans et ça
aussi ça des impact sur notre capacité
d'accueil oui
il y a des dizaines et des dizaines de
milliers d'immigrants d'immigrants
temporaires sur le territoire du Québec
et la première chose à faire c'est de
créer une voie rapide pour ces gens-là
puis ces gens-là monsieur le commandant
je vous rassure d'accord ils sont déjà
dans un appartement ils ont déjà un
logement on n'a pas à choisir entre
régler la publicités
rapports de force avec ottawom sur le
groupe vous avez dit pour éviter que le
Québec devienne la Louisiane il faut
rapatrier tous les pouvoirs on en est où
là dedans est-ce que tout le monde
s'entend il faut rapatrier tous les
pouvoirs en immigration d'abord c'est
important de se réplique le gouvernement
du Québec en 1977 aurait patrié 60% la
sélection des immigrants donc on a déjà
eu des gains on a fait des gains sur
d'autres sujets avec le gouvernement
fédéral mais c'est certain si tous les
partis se mettent ensemble les Québécois
appuient leur rapat plus de pouvoir mais
on va voir plus de chances d'avoir un
succès
d'abord le 60% là autant les libéraux
que le PQ quand il était là et acceptait
qu'il y en ait seulement 50 % qui parle
français donc faut augmenter c'est
pourcentage là on l'augmenter à 80% donc
commençons par ceux qu'on contrôle
je vais vous entendre sur votre
opposition la loi 96 qu'est-ce que
là-dedans qui pour vous est totalement
inacceptable est-ce qu'il fallait pas
agir pour stopper ce déclin que le qu'on
a constaté dans les derniers chiffres il
faut agir pour le français puis faire en
sorte que dans le centre-ville de
Montréal on est des mesures claires
d'accompagnement de nos entreprises puis
de nos commerces ça il faut le faire
puis soutenir en fait les enfants dans
notre système d'éducation également dont
on parlait tout à l'heure mais ce qu'il
ne faut pas faire c'est enlever des
droits à la communauté anglophone il ne
faut pas faire
on a voté contre le projet de loi 96 on
a voté contre le projet loi 21 et vous
ce que vous me dites pas en anglais
c'est que vous voulez aller encore plus
loin sur le projet de voie 21 sur lequel
vous avez voté en faveur vous voulez
vous l'avez pas dit dans les deux
interdire interdire l'accès au Cégep en
anglais pour des francophones et des
allophone vous visez davantage les
allophones mais vous les vous les
interdirez aussi pour les francophones
en quoi ça va aider la langue française
les démographes et les experts nous
disent que c'est une langue de
socialisation cégep qui influence la
langue du travail donc si on veut un
plan complet et on prend acte du déclin
rapide du français on va ramener les
seuils en proportion de notre capacité
d'accueil on va faire une vraie loi 96
avec des mesures structurantes comme la
loi 101 cégep une immigration 100%
économique mais également des mesures
pour que la loi 101 s'applique dans les
entreprises à Chartres fédéral on va
donc investir aussi la culture mais la
loi 96 c'est comme un remède placebo
essentiellement tous les experts sont
venus dire ça ne renversera pas le
déclin du français mais monsieur Legault
nous dit ben c'est quand même quelque
chose moi je pense qu'on est le seul
parti à dire on peut pas se contenter de
quelque chose sur le français mettons en
place une vraie loi 101 réformée qui de
manière structurelle nous garantit de
donner un avenir au fait français en
Amérique une durabilité Atlant de
communes est-ce que vous pourriez aller
plus loin dans un autre mandat le cégep
ou aller plus loin c'est pas ça la clé
puis d'ailleurs même monsieur
Saint-Pierre plat Mondon en 2020 dans sa
première course à Chevry qui était
contre le fait d'étendre la loi sage au
cégep la clé c'est l'intégration aux
Français des nouveaux arrivants pour
interdire comme veut le faire monsieur
saint-pierre-la-mondon à des
francophones d'aller perfectionner leur
anglais dans un cégep anglophone
savez-vous pourquoi j'ai changé d'idées
parce qu'il y a des dizaines d'experts
que vous avez entendu comme moi
l'Assemblée nationale qui sont venus
dire que votre projet de loi renverse
pas le français et ils nous ont soumis
des mesures comme celle-là et moi je ne
suis pas un climato-sceptique de la
langue puis je veux pas qu'on se
contente de Demi mesures décoratives
alors qu'on sait de décliner votre
accélérer jamais on ne veut en 4 ans un
déclin aussi important de la langue
française que sous votre gouverne
monsieur Lego et vous en avez la
responsabilité
très bien là ici trois ans son passé
depuis l'adoption de la loi monsieur
Legouge pas je lance le débat avec vous
et c'est ouvert à tout le monde quels
ont été d'après vous les effets positifs
de cette loi l'interdiction des signes
religieux je pense ça apaisé le peuple
québécois on a eu toutes sortes de
propositions on est allé avec une
proposition équilibrée qui va beaucoup
moins loin qu'en France où on dit les
personnes qui sont en autorité pourront
pas porter de signes religieux quand ils
font 400 en fonction ça veut dire que la
personne chez elle sur la rue peut
porter tous les signes religieux mais en
fonction ces personnes là par respect
pour leurs clients pour leurs élèves
doivent être pas avoir de signes
religieux je pense que il faut pas
rouvrir le débat comme certains veulent
le faire ici mais c'était justement ma
question madame anglaise monsieur
Gabriel ado Dubois vous voulez rouvrir
le débat et replonger le Québec dans ce
débat déchirant j'entends j'entends le
Premier ministre j'entends nous dire ah
ben oui ça apaisé le peuple québécois
c'est qui le peuple québécois c'est quoi
un Québécois aujourd'hui
tous ceux qui vivent au Québec il y a
bien des gens qui vivent au Québec qui
ne pensent pas que ça apaisé les choses
au contraire ça crée des clivages on
sait que on sait que les on sait que
aujourd'hui au Québec on prend des
décisions à l'Assemblée nationale qui
n'ont rien à voir avec la religion rien
à voir on est un peuple laïque on le
sait mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on est
obligé encore une fois de diviser les
Québécois pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'est
pas capable de permettre à des
enseignants d'aller enseignants on vient
de parler en fait tout un débat sur
l'éducation d'enseigner peu importe ce
qu'il porte on a ça ne nous enlève rien
et ça permet
de permettre aux gens d'aller Dubois
c'est à peu près la même position chez
vous c'est à dire que le débat vous
dites qu'il est clos monsieur Lego dit
qu'il est clos moi ce que je vois c'est
que ce pourquoi il continue à exister au
Québec la loi elle est contestée devant
les tribunaux donc malheureusement bon
monsieur Legault le débat il continue et
c'est normal parce que c'est une loi qui
ne fait pas l'unanimité au Québec il y a
des gens qui ont été blessés par cette
loi puis nous ce qu'on va faire c'est
très simple on va garder ce qu'il y a de
bon dans la loi 21 parce que la laïcité
c'est important de l'affirmer la
séparation entre l'Église et les toasts
une valeur démocratique importante mais
on va s'assurer que si une femme veut
travailler dans une école ben puisse le
faire même si elle porte un foulard moi
je pense que ce qu'il faut c'est
appliquer une vraie laïcité aux
institutions et permettent aux individus
de vivre leur vie ça c'est une vision
solidaire de c'est quoi une vraie
laïcité qui marche pour tout le monde
qui rassemble respectivement
vous avez cédé aux radicaux de votre
partie parce que vous disiez exactement
le contraire la dernière fois si les
autres parties peuvent donner leur
position
québécois on constate que pendant plus
de 10 ans on a débattu de cette question
là il y a pas un argument qu'on n'a pas
entendu on a fait une loi un choix
démocratique une loi certes est
imparfaite aux jeux de presque tout le
monde au Québec mais c'est notre loi et
en ce moment le fédéral et des
municipalités canadiennes attaquent
l'invalidation de nos choix
démocratiques et c'est fort probable que
les tribunaux canadiens vont invalider
autant la loi sur la laïcité que la loi
101 et le fédéralisme de François
Legault va faire à ce moment-là mais il
y a une notion on a le droit de décider
par nous-mêmes et décider par soi-même
c'est avoir un pays c'est être
indépendant au Parti conservateur du
Québec qui ont croit la liberté
religieuse évidemment c'est en dit la
liberté des uns arrête là où la liberté
des autres commencent et je pense que
tout citoyen au Québec au droit d'avoir
des services publics de façon neutre
c'est pas compliqué le principe c'est
pas il y a rien c'est pas contre une
religion c'est pas contre un symbole
c'est strictement le fait qu'en tant que
citoyen on a droit quand on fait affaire
avec l'État d'avoir le accès à des
services totalement neutres est-ce que
le débat qu'on entend moins parce que
l'axe fédéralisme n'est plus et que
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire ce
qu'il était est-ce que ce débat là
monsieur Legault est terminé d'après
vous pour 10 15 20 ans il y aura
toujours des gens qui sont
souverainistes et puis je pense que
c'est un projet qui est légitime mais ce
que je sens actuellement c'est que la
majorité des Québécois pour aux autres
c'est pas une priorité actuellement
court terme c'est l'inflation à moyen
terme c'est de relever le défi des
changements climatiques qui ont d'autres
priorités que faire un référendum sur la
souveraineté si elle veut référendum
monsieur Legault vous voteriez oui on en
veut pas de référence
à diviserait des Québécois ce que je
conclue demain matin il y avait un
référendum pour répondre à votre
question à ma gauche ce serait oui ce
serait oui avec Québec solidaire ce
serait mes billes avec le Parti
conservateur puis peut-être avec avec
monsieur Legault avec nous ce serait non
le choix est clair on est imparti
fédéraliste et j'aimerais juste préciser
une journée quand on dit quand on dit
parti fédéralisme ça veut pas dire
s'écraser des rapports à Ottawa ça veut
dire être un partenaire un partenaire et
pas un adversaire nous on veut
travailler avec Ottawa et Monsieur Lego
vous me regardez en disant oui le
partenariat les meilleurs partenariats
c'est quand deux personnes se respectent
et c'est comme ça ce qu'on voit le
fédération fondamentale de ce qu'on peut
juste monsieur le Gaulle la semaine
dernière en débat a dit au Parti libéral
qui leur avis le titre du parti le plus
contre l'indépendance du Québec vous
avez dit ça et vous vous targuez d'être
non seulement fédéraliste mais vous vous
mentez d'être le plus fédéraliste votre
projet s'est détendre l'indépendance du
Québec le mien c'est de le relancer et
il y a des électeurs qui vous ont fait
confiance en 2018 parce qu'il voulait
remplacer les libéraux mais qui sont
indépendantistes moi je fais un appel à
ces gens-là puis je dis vous pouvez
maintenant voter suivant vos convictions
et ce que François Legault a essayé de
faire c'est d'éteindre un mouvement
légitime et surtout déterminer
le but là c'était justement d'arrêter
cette chicane le mousquet je suis fier
c'est que cette élection possiblement
potentiellement tourner la page sur 50
60 ans de chican au Québec on va unir
les Québécois on va parler d'une seule
voix on va être unis sur un paquet de
revendications par rapport à votre
avenir et on va arrêter de vouloir
commencer à ouvrir les chicanes
constitutionnels derrière nous s'il vous
plaît monsieur Roy la question que les
gens doivent se poser à la maison ce
soir c'est ce que notre système
politique au Québec qui fonctionne bien
ce que notre démocratie est en santé
est-ce qu'on est en train de réussir
notre lutte contre les changements
climatiques puis la réponse à ces
questions-là c'est non les gens
participent de moins en moins à nos
élections les gens ont pas de pouvoir
les élections le Premier ministre
beaucoup trop de pouvoir au Québec peu
importe qui était si dans ce siège là ce
qui nous faut c'est un nouveau système
politique au Québec et pour nous c'est
ça le projet d'un nouveau Québec d'un
Québec pays c'est un Québec où on
repense notre système politique pour
répondre à une voix qu'on se rassemble
merci j'en profite pour dire vous avez
été exemplaire dans et le partage du
temps est pas mal équitable
une petite vitre pour vous
j'en ai quelques-unes est-ce qu'on doit
encore au Québec prêter allégeance à la
Couronne britannique a donc à Charles
vous crois
inefficace on a l'inflation qui est en
train d'étrangler les familles puis eux
ils veulent partir un débat sur la
légende
mais c'est c'est la question et voilà
l'animateur avait posé la question
d'abord merci bien je vais vous faire
entendre j'ai rencontré une artiste
peintre qui est en train de créer une
oeuvre c'est très court je vous demande
d'écouter on revient tout de suite
c'est quoi le plan même pour la
prochaine année tu parles de pénurie de
main d'oeuvre mais les artistes nous on
est là
super comment encourager les jeunes
Québécois à consommer davantage de
culture du Québec tour de table je
commence avec vous monsieur devez
rapidement bah écoutez c'est sûr que ça
a été une industrie qui l'a eu très
difficile ces deux dernières années vous
comprenez c'est peut-être l'industrie
qui a été la plus poquée d'une certaine
façon justement eu la chance hier de
dîner avec plusieurs artistes et je sais
que ces gens-là ce qu'ils veulent
d'abord et avant tout c'est une
reconnaissance de ce qui viennent de
vivre puis on a une urgent besoin qu'on
les encourage individuellement c'est
tout très bien il faut donner la piqûre
de la culture québécoise à nos jeunes le
plus tôt possible dans leur vie nous on
a proposé de mettre en place quatre
particules
obligatoires dans toutes les écoles du
Québec parce que qu'on soit né à Parc
Extension à rouynes-noranda ou à
Sherbrooke on devrait tous et toutes
quand on est jeune avoir le même accès à
la culture québécoise ici on leur donne
la piqûre assez tôt bah c'est jeune là
vont devenir des citoyens citoyennes qui
consomment plein de cultures québécoises
ça je pense que c'est un pas en avant ça
va aider le secteur culturel ça va aider
nos jeunes c'est une excellente
proposition ou un passeport culturel qui
ressemble mais la culture c'est
l'essentiel de l'avenir du français et
ça prend un bureau de promotion de du
contenu culturel québécois on veut
également doubler les budgets
Télé-Québec avec un mandat de faire des
émissions québécoises soutenir tous les
budgets de création et en faire la
promotion ça prend également un crtq
c'est à dire que le Québec doit pouvoir
réglementer ce qui est sur nos ondes
parce qu'en ce moment c'est un
raz-de-marée chez les jeunes de très
bien anglais je le vis quotidiennement
avec les trois enfants à la maison mais
trois ados consommation de contenu qui
est en anglais sur les plateformes
numériques il faut absolument investir
davantage ces plateformes-là avec du
contenu francophone puis ça ça va nous
permettre non seulement de développer
l'aspect culturel et francophone ici au
Québec encore plus mais de rayonner à
l'international puis de penser que on
est dans le monde des centaines de
millions de personnes à parler français
et ça permettrait au Québec de se
positionner encore plus fort monsieur
LEGO en 2018 le budget de la culture au
Québec c'était 1,2 milliards par année
cette année c'est 1,7 milliards par
année on a augmenté le budget de
49%. on a ajouté des sorties culturelles
j'essaie d'encourager la lecture sur mes
médias sociaux puis on a annoncé que
sont élus 65 millions de plus je vous
aimerez peut-être pas ça pour
Télé-Québec pour plus d'émissions
québécoises très heureux tant mieux tout
le monde se porte bien
rapidement là c'est un exercice que je
vais vous demander quel est votre plus
grand d'inquiétude pour les quatre
prochaines années tour de table inverse
très rapidement
l'économie verte là ça presse de réduire
nos GS puis créer de la richesse avoir
une vision pour la lutte au changement
climatique et régler la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre
les deux enjeux le plus structurant
c'est le français l'environnement pour
ça ça prend transparence et de la
confiance vis-à-vis des gouvernements
Gabriel ado Dubois votre plus grande
agilité contre les changements
climatiques faut aider les familles à
sortir la tête de la crise de
l'inflation c'est les trois c'est les
deux priorités pour les quatre
prochaines années Eric Dream le pouvoir
d'achat des familles québécoises
d'inflation c'est ça qu'il faut c'est ça
le problème des familles québécois
vous avez été vraiment exemplaire est-ce
que c'est la dernière élection monsieur
Legros avec ce mode de scrutin où on va
plus là-dedans vous reprenez plus ça
jamais avec l'appendémie là je sens que
c'est vraiment pas une priorité des
Québécois c'est pour vous êtes d'accord
les madame anglais non c'est pas dans
notre programme puis le jour ce sera
dans notre programme on va le faire on
peut juste l'écrire on va le faire et
vous trouverez un engagement qu'on va
respecter notre parole il y a pas de
raison que monsieur Legault ne respecte
pas sa parole la démocratie là Monsieur
Rouen c'est les moyens qu'on se donne de
régler tous les autres problèmes au
Québec moi je veux qu'on ait une
démocratie plus orientée ça prend un
meilleur moment je peux le promettre
parce que j'ai vu Justin Trudeau le
promettre il l'a pas fait j'ai vu
François Legault le promet puis il l'a
pas fait merci
beaucoup c'est terminé elle ça va très
très vite merci beaucoup je pense que
les gens ont compris à la maison
j'espère que ça a été éclairant je le
crois sincèrement le temps de parole a
été pas mal équitable merci à l'équipe
en régie
préparation sans vous ça aurait pas
exister tout ça mesdames et messieurs
votre parenticipation en fin de semaine
on se voit le 3 octobre bonne soirée
[Musique]
bonsoir tout le monde bienvenue
au point de presse de la chaîne sportive
du Québec on va avoir 7 minutes en
français 3 minutes en anglais s'il vous
plaît vous limitez à une question un
suivi par respect pour vos collègues
je voudrais vous entendre sur la façon
dont François Legout traite les femmes
vous avez eu un moment donné même la
difficulté à prendre votre place ce soir
c'est vos collègues vous adversaires qui
vous ont laissé cette place là puis
monsieur le goût dit que vous voulez
mettre en lumière qu'il traite
inéquitablement les femmes c'est quoi la
relation que vous reprochez à François
Legault et sa façon de traiter les
femmes la première chose que j'aimerais
vous dire par rapport à votre question
c'est que je pense que j'ai pris ma
place ce soir parce que j'ai imposé une
certaine nombre de thèmes qui m'était
cher qui qui vraiment témoignait de ce
qu'on veut faire au Parti libéral du
Québec première chose deuxième chose
c'est qu'il y a des enjeux fondamentaux
au Québec qui ont frappé les femmes
davantage la covid a frappé les femmes
davantage on a voulu tourner dans tous
les sens mais les services de garde
c'est un être recul pour les femmes il
veut pas le reconnaître il veut pas dire
mais c'est la vérité alors quand on est
capable de reconnaître un problème on
est capable de travailler par rapport à
ça c'est pas ce qu'il fait je pense que
c'est important de soulever ça parce que
les femmes c'est 50% de la population au
Québec est-ce que vous avez l'impression
fondamentalement que François Legault
traite inéquitablement les femmes
actuellement au Québec ici je pense
qu'il sous-estime les enjeux qui sont
reliés aux enjeux aux enjeux des femmes
on le voit avec les on le voit avec les
CPE puis lorsqu'on parle des enjeux des
femmes par exemple on a parlé des des
professeurs c'est comme si des
professeurs puis des enseignants c'est
comme si
la seule solution c'est l'augmentation
de salaire c'est pas juste ça c'est
l'impact de de la charge de travail la
charge mentale ce que les femmes vivent
au quotidien ne pas sentir que tu es à
ta place au travail ne pas sentir que tu
es à ta place à la maison seuls les
femmes le vivent partout tout le temps
au Québec alors c'est c'est de
reconnaître que ça existe et je pense
pas qu'il est vraiment cette sensibilité
là ça fait partie de ce que j'apporte
aussi en politique
le gouvernement de François Legault ne
prend pas la pleine mesure des impacts
des décisions sur les femmes
l'exemple des services de garde sans
état quand on parle des enseignants sans
état quand on parle de nos infirmières
qui sont obligés de faire du temps
supplémentaire obligatoire sans être un
autre alors il faut réfléchir en
fonction de ça également si vous êtes
que vous avez pris votre place vous vous
donnez une bonne note je vais vous
laisser l'évaluer mais cela ferait vous
êtes bon dans les notes non cette
question sentez-vous que vous avez bien
performer j'ai donné le meilleur de
moi-même
merci
bonjour madame Anglade Mylène crainte de
la presse j'aimerais justement savoir
qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé de cet
échange justement sur la place des
femmes sur les garderies avec monsieur
Legault il vous a interrompu l'animateur
du rappel à l'ordre oui et puis il m'a
même dit encore comment la formuler seul
j'ai oublié exactement mais comme encore
ce thème ce thème il est important ce
thème de la place des femmes dans notre
société il est important puis si on veut
construire un Québec où on se rassemble
on se divise pas il faut prendre en
considération aussi ce que vivent les
femmes au Québec c'était ça mon message
puis il faut savoir nommer les choses je
l'ai nommé mais qu'est-ce que vous avez
pensé de l'échange avec monsieur Legault
de la façon dont il vous a répondu
toujours de manière paternaliste
d'approcher les choses toujours une
manière de dire des choses
alors que ce qu'on veut là c'est qu'il y
a une véritable compréhension de ce qui
se passe monsieur Legault un style de
leadership où il aime imposer sa manière
de penser moi j'ai un style de
leadership qui veut rassembler qui
écoute qui entend ce qui se passe sur le
terrain puisqu'il est capable de
traduire ça dans des propositions qui
sont concrètes que j'ai présentées
d'ailleurs ce soir c'est pas ce style de
leadership que François Legault a c'est
le mien et c'est ce que j'amène en
politique merci merci
bonjour Marc-André Gagnon du journal
madame Anglade on vous a vu dans les
derniers jours avec des gants de boxe un
moment donné où était vos gants de boxe
ce soir
j'ai toujours des gants de boxe j'ai
toujours voulu dire quoi quand vous les
aimez le meilleur de moi-même mais en
même temps est-ce que vous auriez été ce
que vous auriez pu être plus à l'attaque
un peu plus combatif non ah ben je pense
que j'ai été très compatible je pense
que dans les propos je suis intervenu
quand il fallait j'étais parler des
enjeux de pénurie de main d'oeuvre j'ai
soulevé des enjeux qui sont très humains
que vivent que vivent les Québécois puis
dans les propos que j'ai tenu j'ai parlé
beaucoup avec mon coeur aussi de ce que
les gens vivent de ce que j'entends sur
le terrain puis de ce que j'observe moi
comme mère de famille comme comme
citoyenne du Québec non je pense que
j'ai été j'ai dit ce que j'avais à dire
parce que depuis le début de votre
campagne on a vu cette tuile après tuile
à quel point ce soir c'est un moment
important décisif pour la suite des
choses dans votre campagne c'est un
moment important mais ce que je peux
vous dire par contre c'est que je vais
continuer à travailler sans relâche
jusqu'au 3 octobre les gens qui me
connaissent le savent je manque pas
d'énergie je manque pas de
d'éléments pour vraiment pousser la
machine jusqu'au fond et je vais
continuer de le faire
bonjour madame Langlade pour le soleil
François Legault attaquer beaucoup
Gabriel Lanaud Dubois durant ce débat
est-ce que vous êtes senti ignoré par le
Premier ministre moi je regarde les
temps de parole puis je pense que j'ai
eu des temps de parole je pense que je
suis dans le milieu là dans les temps de
parole qui ont été faits alors je pense
que sur l'économie on a eu de très bons
échanges qui montrent bien et qui
contraste la vision de François Legault
avec notre vision qu'on veut amener d'un
point de vue d'un point de vue
économique et ça déconnexion par rapport
à plusieurs anges vous pensez pas que le
premier ministre ne vous voit pas comme
une menace
c'est pas à lui de choisir ses
adversaire c'est au Québécois c'est au
Québécois de choisir il a déjà fait
quand il nous a dit de pour qui voter
aux fédéral c'est pas à lui de décider
merci
je posais la question de différent
là-bas est-ce que ce débat là a pu c'est
un peu servir à redresser votre campagne
il peut surtout servir à informer tous
les Québécois sur les propositions qu'on
veut amener j'ai eu l'opportunité d'en
présenter plusieurs sur différents
thèmes puis moi j'ai aimé l'exercice
j'ai mis l'exercice de dire ben voici ce
qu'on amène voici ce qu'on propose et
voilà comment ça se différencie des
autres alors contente très contente du
résultat et vous pensez donc ça peut
permettre de convaincre des Québécois de
la pertinence ou de faire des gains ce
soir parce que
je pense que les Québécois qui regardent
ça aujourd'hui disent ah mais peut-être
que je savais pas telle affaire ça c'est
intéressant cette manière de faire cette
manière aussi d'être d'avoir un
leadership plus collaboratif ce qu'on
n'a pas avec la CAQ aujourd'hui partout
partout dans toutes les décisions qu'il
prend François Legault impose sa manière
de faire collabore pas avec les villes
il leur dit quoi faire collabore pas
avec le fédéral il fait leur dit quoi
faire collabore pas j'ai un leadership
qui est collaboratif qui fait que tout
le monde peut s'asseoir à la table et
qu'il fait aussi que tout le monde se
sent représenter qu'on arrête de diviser
les Québécois comme il le fait notamment
sur les enjeux d'immigration mais de
manière générale comment être divise le
Québécois merci 2 minutes 30 on va
passer en anglais malheureusement c'est
tout en français
que
technique
[Musique]
shader Andy is that my you and fury
merci
c'est complet merci à tous merci
beaucoup
c'est très calme
je n'entends rien
ouais
bonjour alors Monsieur nado Duba va
avoir une petite affirmation ensuite on
va prendre vos questions on a seulement
10 minutes donc on se concentrera à une
question une sous question merci bonsoir
très heureux d'avoir débattu ce soir de
l'avenir du Québec je voulais parler de
crise climatique je voulais parler de
crise du logement je voulais te positif
aussi parler du projet de société qu'on
a Québec solidaire je pense que j'ai
atteint ces objectifs là pendant ce
temps-là ce que je constate c'est que
François Legault continue à critiquer le
plan environnemental de Québec solidaire
sans rien proposer de concret sans
proposer aucun projet positif pour que
le Québec soit plus efficace dans sa
lutte au changement climatique donc
malheureusement monsieur Legault aura
raté l'occasion de présenter son projet
au Québécois québécois moi je pense que
c'est ce que j'ai fait ce soir
bonjour monsieur nado Dubois François
caramel devoir vous l'avez dit monsieur
Legault vous a attaqué frontalement dès
les premières minutes du débat sur votre
plan vert il dit que vous vous êtes
Gabriel au pays des merveilles
essentiellement
comment vous expliquer cette stratégie
là du premier ministre est-ce que vous
vous sentez même pas un peu utiliser
c'est à lui à justifier ces stratégies
moi je constate que François Legault est
pas à la hauteur de la situation en ce
moment là la crise climatique elle
appelle des leaders qui sont capables de
rassembler les gens puis de proposer des
solutions donner des choix écologiques
aux gens François Legault est passé
journée à critiquer le parti que le
meilleur plan d'environnement et lui il
propose rien chez le goût vit dans une
autre époque il a une vision d'une autre
époque et sa paru ce soir
en fin de débats sur le goût vous a
aussi reproché d'avoir cédé aux radicaux
je décide de votre partie sur la loi 21
qu'est-ce que vous lui répondez puis
comment vous justifier que vous ayez
quand même changé votre position sur la
loi 21 maintenant qu'on a la même
position à Québec solidaire monsieur
Legault cherche toutes sortes de
manières de nous attaquer parce que lui
son projet pour le Québec c'est un
projet d'une autre époque il est pas
capable d'enthousiasmer les Québécois
québécoises derrière son projet donc ce
qui fait c'est nous attaquer mais vous
avez possédé
la position de Québec solidaire et la
même depuis des années maintenant
bonjour
Journal de Québec lorsque vous sortez
d'un exercice comme celui-là vous dites
est-ce que vous trouvez que vous avez
mieux réussi votre coup ce soir que la
semaine dernière
je pense que dans les deux cas j'ai
atteint les objectifs que je m'étais
donné ce soir j'avais envie oui d'être
combatif mais surtout d'être positif
puis de dire au Québécois québécoises
c'est quoi le projet de société qu'on a
Québec solidaire je pense que le
contraste était évident avec un François
Legault qui lui est toujours négatif
quand il parle d'environnement à part
des barrages imaginaires là il y a rien
à proposer au Québécois québécois
voyez-vous vous m'amener ma prochaine
question parce que j'ai eu l'impression
que ce soit vous avez sorti davantage la
cassette que dans le précédent débats
vous avez répété à deux reprises par
exemple monsieur Legault arrêtez de
sortir les déclarations d'Halloween
ce que je me trompe dans mon analyse
c'était plus la cassette sur laquelle
vous êtes appuyé j'ai parlé avec mon
cœur ce soir comme j'ai parlé à mon avec
mon coeur l'autre soir moi je trouve ça
triste que le Québec a été gouverné
pendant 4 ans par un politiqueien qui a
si peu d'ambition si peu de vision pour
l'avenir et qui à chaque fois que les
questions d'environnement au lieu de
dire voici mon plan il raconte des
histoires de peur au Québécois québécois
sur ce dommage merci
je vais continuer sur ce décor
d'Halloween et cette notion de faire
peur au monde
j'ai pas l'impression que justement les
ce concepts de taxe orange là ça
commence ça commence à passer plus les
gens commencent à se dire au moins
l'impôt sur le patrimoine puis là les
véhicules énergivores vous avez pas
l'impression que ça se tourne un peu
contre vous quand même moi je pense que
à Québec solidaire on a l'avantage de la
sincérité puis de la transparence
il y a des partis politiques pendant des
années on dit au Québec oui oui c'est
important l'environnement
mais il y a rien qui va changer vous
inquiétez pas moi ce que je dis aux gens
du Québec c'est avec nous les choses
vont changer on est capable ensemble de
changer nos habitudes d'avoir des
meilleurs habitudes de transport on
s'attaque à un tabou c'est vrai mais moi
je pense que ça prend quelqu'un au
Québec pour dire la vérité là-dessus sur
la crise du logement vous l'avez répété
cette semaine moi je veux l'amener dans
le débat la crise du logement on en a
parlé à peine sincèrement trois quatre
minutes est-ce que c'est suffisant
est-ce qu'on a suffisamment débattuces
j'en ai parlé moi le plus possible mais
non je trouve que ça pas pris assez de
place dans le débat je suis
systématiquement le seul à parler de la
crise du logement je veux dire on dit
qu'une crise du coût de la vie mais
c'est quoi le premier poste de dépenses
de toutes les familles du Québec qui
soit locataire ou propriétaire c'est
toujours le loyer ou l'hypothèque c'est
le logement moi j'en ai parlé je suis
content de l'avoir fait mais je remarque
que trop souvent c'est évacué quand on
parle du coup de la vie alors que
pourtant c'est absolument essentiel
merci
bonjour Anne-Sophie poiry
il y a plusieurs études qui démontent
que l'adaptation changement climatique
ça va coûter encore plus cher si on
attend il faut investir massivement
maintenant
par contre l'adaptation changeant
climatique pratiquement en fait ne pas
été discuté jamais en débat c'est à
peine mentionné dans votre plateforme
électorale donc qu'est-ce que vous
comptez faire concrètement pour
aider les villes à s'adapter au
changement climatique
d'un fond d'urgence climatique on va
mettre 500 millions de dollars par année
de côté pour avoir de l'argent quand nos
enfants puis nos petits-enfants vont
devoir investir pour faire face au
changement climatique c'est dans notre
cas de financier j'en ai parlé à
plusieurs reprises depuis le début de la
campagne je suis tout à fait d'accord il
faut à la fois lutter pour ralentir les
changements climatiques et investir
massivement pour s'adapter au changement
climatique qui vont irrémédiablement se
produire au Québec dans une certaine
proportion donc 500 milliards de 500
millions de dollars par année merci
en anglais alors
programme au Québec solidaire I thinké
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
monsieur Lego va faire une allocution
monsieur Lego oui bonsoir tout le monde
ben écoutez j'ai beaucoup aimé le débat
je trouve qu'on a eu des bons échanges
entre autres sur l'équilibre entre
environnement puis l'économie donc
l'importance de réduire nos GES mais
sans évidemment aller vider les poches
des Québécois sans les fermer des
entreprises donc je trouve qu'on a eu un
bon échange équilibre environnement je
pense qu'on a eu aussi des bons échanges
sur le portefeuille des Québécois donc
d'un côté il y a les impôts mais il y a
de l'aide à court terme qui doit être
donné en 2022 pour faire face à
l'inflation donc j'ai pu répéter là que
dès le mois de décembre les Québécois
vont avoir en 400$ si gagne moins de 100
000 puis les personnes de 70 ans et plus
vont avoir un 2000 dollars de plus dès
cette année en 2022 donc je pense que de
façon générale bon on a parlé aussi de
santé on a parlé
d'éducation on a parlé de la protection
du français donc j'ai aimé les échanges
qu'on a eu ce soir très content on va
prendre une question pour donner la
chance à tout le monde première question
monsieur Saint-Pierre playmondon c'est
attaqué à vos seuils d'immigration parce
que vous avez admis qu'un chiffre 50 000
contribués au reculent du français
qu'est-ce que vous comptez mettre en
œuvre pour éviter que ce soit le cas
dans le passé puis c'est ce que j'ai dit
Monsieur saint-pierre-lamondon c'est
autant un gouvernement du PQ un
gouvernement libéral ils ont accepté que
50% des immigrants choisis par le Québec
par pas français nous l'année dernière
il y en avait seulement 20% on a réussi
à en avoir 80% qui parlaient français
avant d'être choisi va falloir continuer
en cette direction là d'abord plus grand
pourcentage
est-ce que vous vous engagez à le
maintenir à 80%. c'est notre objectif
oui effectivement ça c'est réaliste oui
on pense que c'est réaliste
entre autres en visant les régions en
visant les étudiants qui viennent
étudier dans les collèges plus
universités francophones donc moi
j'étais à l'aise avec le 50 000 je pars
à l'aise du tout avec le 70000 puis
80000 de Québec solidaire du Parti
libéral mais avec le 50 000 si on
choisit bien nos immigrants qui sont
sélectionnés par Québec si on exige de
connaître le français pour la grande
majorité je pense qu'on est capable d'y
arriver prochaine question
est-ce que vous traitez mal les femmes
ben écoutez ça met un peu choqué cette
attaque là qui revient souvent de la
part de Madame Anglade parce qu'avec
Sonia Lebel on ne fait tellement pour
les femmes là écoutez je le rappelle
c'était la première fois dans l'histoire
du Québec qu'on a donné des
augmentations de salaire différenciés
puis ces trois groupes de femmes qui ont
eu des augmentations
par dire qu'on a augmenté les salades et
préposés aux initiales qui sont surtout
des femmes ici éducatrices en garderie
qui sont surtout des femmes que les
enseignants qui sont sortis maintenant
madame anglais des garderies je trouve
qu'elle est tellement mal placé par les
dégâts de riz parce que d'abord
rappelons que le gouvernement libéral
avait mis une taxe on s'en rappelle il y
avait augmenté le tarif des garderies
nous on le remis à un tarif unique en
orbaissé on corriger l'erreur des
libéraux que les libéraux à cause de
Tony Tomassi avait 12 étapes ça prenait
cinq ans pour créer une place on a
corrigé ça aussi donc je trouve que même
englade tellement mal placé pour faire
ce genre d'accusation prochaine question
bonsoir monsieur Legault le soleil je
repose la question de Monsieur dumm sur
le troisième lien qui fait l'étude et
combien coûte-t-elle bon c'est le bureau
de projet ok le bureau de projet et géré
par des fonctionnaires et par des
consultants qui font faire les études
donc c'est pas le politique c'est que de
ça c'est bureau de projet même pas
répondu sur le coup je vais imposer une
deuxième question encore sur le
troisième lien on a parlé beaucoup dans
les derniers temps pourquoi vous êtes
que je vous ai pas répondu sur le coup
je vous ai demandé combien l'étude ok
mais je vais aussi poser ma deuxième
question si vous me permettez on en a
parlé beaucoup du troisième lien aussi
bon au début on avait une étude on
voulait pas la sortir après ça on avait
plus d'études
est-ce que le troisième livre est en
train de devenir la pas du tout parce
que d'abord les études qui ont été
faites c'est sur un lien à l'est à six
voix là nous ce qu'on propose depuis un
an suite au consultation c'est un tunnel
4 voies centre-ville à centre-ville qui
va beaucoup aider le transport collectif
puisqu'il fait pas mal consensus à
Québec et à Lévy on va prendre pour la
question prochaine question s'il vous
plaît merci
est-ce que vous estimez au terme de
votre performance de votre débat que
vous méritez les quatre années que vous
demandez au Québécois ben écoutez c'est
OK quoi de répondre à ça là je veux pas
prendre la décision le 3 octobre on va
avoir la réponse de Québécois j'espère
qu'ils vont me donner leurs confiance on
a remarqué ce soir que j'avais fait
beaucoup d'attaques contre Monsieur
Nanou Dubois est-ce que vous êtes en
train de valider ici
ces prétentions sont laquelle c'est une
course seulement à deux c'est parce
qu'on est pardon on est tous au Québec
d'accord qu'il faut lutter contre les
changements climatiques qu'on a besoin
d'un plan costaud pour réduire les GES
mais quand monsieur Nadaud Dubois dit
qui veut mettre une taxe orange de 7500
dollars qui veut augmenter la dette de
40 % puis qui veut fermer des
entreprises là Monsieur Nadou du bois un
peu comme au pays des merveilles et je
pense les Québécois doivent comprendre
ça est-ce que vous confirmez une course
à deux comme ça ben écoutez là-dessus là
sur le plan pour réduire les GES
c'est comme de la magie monsieur Nadaud
Dubois là c'est le fun moi aussi
j'aimerais ça aller vite comme lui mais
ça se peut pas faut le dire faut
l'expliquer il nous reste un peu moins
de 2 minutes en français Marco oui
bonsoir monsieur Legault à quoi servira
l'étude sur le troisième lien qui a été
commandé au bureau de projet ça va nous
aider techniquement avoir qu'est-ce que
c'est exactement la meilleure façon de
procède des l'entrée les sorties
l'achalandage prévu le pourcentage qui
se remis pour le transport collectif le
pourcentage qui se remis pour les autos
éventuellement qui seront électriques
donc c'est un peu tout ça qu'on va avoir
dans l'étude mais peu importe les
conclusions vous allez aller de l'avant
avec la conscience
l'étude nous dit que ça prend une
autoroute sur l'île d'Orléans mais je
m'excuse là j'accepterai pas de mettre
une autoroute sur l'île d'Orléans là
c'est là que j'ai dit il y aura une
décision politique
qui a été le meilleur le logo de la
semaine dernière le goût de ce soir et
pourquoi ben je pense peut-être bonne
humeur cette semaine et j'étais de bonne
humeur surtout quand je parlais de mes
idées mais évidemment comme vous l'avez
vu me fait beaucoup attaquer donc là
dans ce temps-là je souris moins une
dernière en français bonjour monsieur
Lego vous a quand même sentiment
patients certains moments dans ce débat
est-ce que vous trouvez vraiment que
votre performance était meilleur que la
semaine dernière
mais j'ai essayé en tout cas de passer
plus mes idées donc c'est jamais facile
de trouver l'équilibre entre être
défensif sur les nombreuses attaques et
être offensif en disant voici ce que la
carte propose parce que il faut qu'il y
a un équilibre dans le temps que les
quatre chefs m'attaquaient moins vous
avez un autre adversaire monsieur duem
que vous s'attaquez peu vous êtes plutôt
concentré sur Gabriel Nadaud Dubois
pourquoi l'attaquer seulement sur la
pandémie monsieur dum je pense que ici
comme disqualifié Éric dum pendant par
des il n'y a pas été solidaire de nos
aînés il y a agi un peu comme quelqu'un
qui profite la situation pour aller
chercher des votes je pense
irresponsable c'est inquiétant et c'est
pour ça que les Québécois s'attendent
d'un leader donc je pense c'était
important et puis je pense que sur ce
sujet là ça le disqualifie on a du temps
pour une en anglais file Queen
[Musique]
leaders that worldie like last week the
wear always again
to propose
merci beaucoup c'est tout le temps qu'on
a merci tout le monde bonne nuit
bonsoir tout le monde d'abord je veux
dire que je suis très satisfait du débat
j'ai beaucoup aimé nos échanges ce soir
ça a permis de mettre en lumière
évidemment la plateforme électorale
notamment du Parti conservateur du
Québec j'ai particulièrement apprécié
les échanges avec monsieur Legault au
sujet du troisième lien j'ai été fort
surpris comme vous j'imagine de voir
qu'il ne savait pas qui allait faire
l'étude dont il parle depuis plusieurs
jours il n'avait aucune idée de combien
ça allait coûter non plus donc il nous
promet il nous a avoué il y a quelques
jours qu'il y avait pas d'études il nous
avoue aujourd'hui que il sait pas qui va
faire l'étude mais il sait qu'il va il
sait déjà la conclusion puis c'est quand
l'étude va être publiée il sait pas
combien va coûter ça de ça devient de
plus en plus complexe et de plus en plus
un nébuleux cette histoire de troisième
lien dans la bouche de monsieur Legault
c'est c'est aussi en contradiction avec
certaines des déclarations qui avaient
faites antérieurement puis comme j'ai
comme vous j'imagine aussi constater ce
soir qu'il ne veut toujours pas public
les études qui le déjà en main sous
prétexte que ce sont des études qui
parlent d'un pont à l'Est qui est
exactement la proposition du Parti
conservateur du Québec et celle que
proposer il y a 4 ans monsieur Legault
donc je pense que Monsieur Legout est en
train de de d'attirer beaucoup
l'attention sur cet enjeu-là
particulièrement pour la grande région
de Québec en vue du scrutin du 3 octobre
prochain sur ce ça va maintenant me
faire plaisir de prendre vos questions
pour la période de questions on aura un
10 minutes donc si possible vous
contenter d'un d'une question puis d'une
question je pense que vos collègues
apprécieront également 8 minutes pour
question en français puis ensuite on
passera aux questions en anglais merci
bonsoir Tayeb bon là journal de
québecs les plus vigoureux là de la
soirée du débat était concernant la
pandémie monsieur le goût vous a traité
d'agitateur d'irresponsable là je le
cite il y a quelques minutes il a dit
que vous êtes disqualifié et puis il a
paru fâché il a quasiment là contre
contre vous pendant 7% comment vous
l'avez vécu ce bout là du débat ben j'ai
été très étonné de Monsieur le goût du
moment où il y a choisi d'aborder cet
enjeux-là on parlait de santé mentale si
vous vous rappelez bien le statut
l'objet du débat au moment où monsieur
Legault est sauté dans la reine et là il
y a des idées de se mettre à m'attaquer
sur les aînés et la crise sanitaire
la crise de la santé mentale de je
respirais que je lis même dit pendant
que des boxs beaucoup moins partisans je
pense que tout le monde ici est à même
de constater que yo au Québec il va y
avoir un problème de santé mentale il y
a des études qui commencent à documenter
le problème la problématique que ça va
que ça va qui va que ça va développer
que lui se servent de ça pour commencer
à dire que on avait abandonné les années
j'ai trouvé ça un peu bizarre parce que
ceux et celles qui vont souffrir
beaucoup de santé mentale il y a des
années évidemment mais il y a surtout
aussi beaucoup de jeunes et ça a été ça
mais mon point puis essayer de le je
comprends qu'il y a de la difficulté à
défendre sa
de défendre son bilan à ce niveau là je
vais juste vous rappeler que par rapport
à la gare de chiffres je sais qu'une
grosse gare de chiffres est-ce qu'il y a
eu plus ou moins de marques hier au
Canada père capita il y a eu plus de
morts au Québec partout ailleurs au
Canada monsieur Legault se sert toujours
de la l'indice de la surmortalité qui
n'a jamais utilisé en passant pendant
les premières années de la crise il y a
toujours parlé de mort puis de mort par
centaines de milliers d'habitants il a
changé la méthodologie pour que
maintenant il y ait des chiffres qui
fassent un peu mieux paraître mais à la
limite c'est que c'est pas ça c'est pas
ça l'enjeu aujourd'hui le l'enjeu c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les enfants
qui souffrent il y a une étude
Université de Sherbrooke qui nous dit
que près de 50% des enfants des jeunes
ont des problèmes d'anxiété ont des
problèmes de dépression moi c'est ça qui
m'interpelle et là-dessus
malheureusement monsieur Legault a pas
commencé à avoir le début du
commencement d'une réponse et évidemment
que le fait que le Québec a sur confiné
ça a eu un impact encore plus
dévastateur sur la santé mentale des
quoi vous avez évoqué en début de débat
la question du pont de Québec oui
comment vous voyez les choses maintenant
sachant il y a une entente entre le
fédéral et le CN le gouvernement du
Québec n'est pas encore dans cette
entente le négociateur accusé le
gouvernement de faire de la petite
politique comment vous il y a pas eu de
réponse la nature il y a pas eu de
réponse puis le temps presse là c'est
d'ici la fin du mois dans quelques jours
on parle c'est même des heures avant la
fin de l'Entente le gouvernement du
Québec c'est traîné les pieds de toute
évidence dans ce dossier là comme dans
le dossier de tous les liens avec la
réussite de Québec regardez ce qui se
passe avec le Pont Pierre Laporte il
veut toujours pas nous dire c'est quoi
le problème pourquoi Pomerlo a enlevé
d'urgence les équipements sur le Pont
Pierre Laporte on sait que il y a des
problèmes avec les suspentes du Pont
Pierre Laporte ils veulent pas donner
leur jus s'il y a pas tout est au neuf
de ce côté là le pont de Québec les
négociations le gouvernement du Québec
de toute évidence se traîne les pieds et
pas très responsable dans ce dossier là
et en plus de ça son troisième qui nous
avait promis il y a quatre ans il y a
pas commencé les travaux contrairement à
ce que certains de ces députés avaient
promis pire que ça il nous dit qu'il y a
tant une étude l'an prochain puis on
arrive dans un débat puis même pas foutu
de nous dire qui fait l'étude puis même
pas foutu de nous dire combien va coûter
cette étude mais il sait déjà les
conclusions de l'étude c'est hallucinant
oui bonsoir Monsieur James
il y a un thème que auquel vous tenez
beaucoup qui celui du privé en santé
est-ce que vous êtes satisfait de la
place qui a été donnée à ce thème là des
échanges que vous avez eu là-dessus dans
le quartier des bas mais je pense que ça
a mis en relief la différence entre le
Parti conservateur du Québec et les
quatre autres parties je crois qu'il y a
une grosse différence sur comment on
peut ajouter j'étais content parce que
même il y a même une question de
l'animateur sur la spécifiquement sur la
place du privé en santé
j'ai particulièrement mis la l'échange
avec Monsieur Nadaud Dubois c'était gare
là qui qui lui disait que s'il y a une
impression que le privé
omniprésent selon ses propres désirs
alors que c'est pas c'est pas du tout
notre perception je pense que les
téléspectateurs ont une meilleure
compréhension j'ai aussi pu exprimer
parce que dans le premier débat il y
avait eu de la confusion puis je m'étais
même ici quand il y a eu cinq chefs un
débat il y a quelques semaines aussi on
comparaissait où à ce qui se passait aux
États-Unis tout ça aujourd'hui j'ai
vraiment eu la chance vous expliquer non
non la carte d'assurance maladie du
Québec va demeurer vous allez pouvoir
aller au public ou au privé s'il y a pas
des délais raisonnables donc ça nous a
vraiment permis de rappeler que ça se
fait à l'intérieur de la Loi canadienne
sur la santé puis qu'on respecte
l'assurance publique donc ça je suis
très très content le qu'on ait pu mettre
ça au clair le pire notre position puis
comparer ça au modèle européen qui nous
ont inspiré notamment la Suède et
l'Allemagne prochaine question peut-être
parce que
sinon juste pour discipline ambiguïté
puisque vous avez comme opposé les
possibles d'essai d'aimer à la santé
mentale des jeunes est-ce qu'on doit
comprendre que pour préserver la santé
mentale des jeunes pendant la pandémie
ça aurait été justifiée d'exposer des
années à des dangers en réduisant l'une
de mesures sanitaires c'est pas moi qui
a posé ça c'est monsieur
Legault qui est sauté dans la mairie
alors qu'on parlait de santé mentale des
enfants qui a commencé à parler des
morts puis des années merci beaucoup
madame Paul c'est son opposition c'est
son opposition le moi j'ai jamais parlé
des c'est lui qui a commencé à
m'attaquer là dessus alors qu'on parlait
de la santé mentale des plus jeunes
monsieur Laberge merci
bonjour Thomas Laberge pour le soleil
bonjour monsieur duem vous parlez bon
beaucoup de privé de concurrence on a un
peu l'impression que pour tous les
problèmes dont on fait face à ceci dit
québécoises c'est un peu toujours la
même solution que vous proposez est-ce
que c'est vrai non quand j'ai parlé du
des ponts on a parlé moi je pense que
l'échange le plus important ce soir qui
était le plus révélateur je pense que
c'est surtout sur le troisième lien
Québec Lévy il était pas question de
priver versus public le c’était
clairement des travaux qui sont faits de
façon publique donc il y a pas eu de on
était pas mono sujet à ce niveau-là je
ne pense pas quand on a eu des échanges
à la santé mentale dont on vient de
parler avec Madame porter c'était pas
non plus un débat entre les privilège
public c'est là où il était question du
privé effectivement c'est en matière de
santé puis c'est sûr puis même un peu en
matière d'éducation aussi c'est vrai
qu'un certain moment il était question
du privé mais en tant que conservateur
c'est notre philosophie politique nous
on croit à la libre concurrence on pense
que effectivement quand il y a plusieurs
joueurs puis qu'il faut qu'ils se font
ultimement c'est le patient l'enfant le
contribuable qui en sort gagnant on ne
croit pas à des gros monopoles qui
soient publics ou privés en passant
c'est pas juste les prix les publics
donc on j'ai pu mettre ça en relief
peut-être ce soir un peu plus que dans
le premier débat là-dessus vous avez
raison merci beaucoup monsieur Laberge
madame Crète j'ai posé une seule
question je suis le temps file donc je
veux juste savoir j'ai posé la question
monsieur est-ce que vous voulez faire du
3e année la question de l'homme vous
avez une c'est beaucoup de l'avant allez
dernier jour mais c'est c'est évident
que c'est une question très importante
c'est de loin le plus gros
investissement de l'histoire de la ville
de Québec c'est la question qui qui fait
je pense qu'il est qu'interpelle le plus
les électeurs ce filtre à moi je vous
avouer là il y a la question de
l'inflation c'est au niveau de la
grandeur du Québec mais dans la région
de Québec j'ai encore fait du
porte-à-porte en fin de semaine c'est
clair et net que la question qui
interpelle les gens de Québec c'est le
tramway et le troisième bien je sais pas
quel pourcentage la population va voter
une fonction du troisième lien ou du
tramway mais je pense que c'est un très
fort pourcentage ça se repose 100% que
la question référendum c'est un peu un
piège parce que c'est pas 100% des gens
et des gens qui m'ont voté sur d'autres
enjeux mais c'est certainement l'enjeu
régional et de loin qui va retenir le
plus l'attention de la population de
Québec ça c'est bien évidemment
merci beaucoup thank you c'est fini
donc une question une sous question
merci
bonsoir monsieur
vous avez dit Monsieur le goût essaye de
d'éteindre le débat de la souveraineté
avez-vous l'impression que ce soir vous
êtes parvenu à rallumer vous ce bol
ça le mérite de créer un choix qui est
important qui mérite une réflexion à
savoir moi je veux relancer
l'indépendantiste mais je pense qu'on
devrait décider par nous-mêmes au Québec
qu'on devrait exister à l'international
François le groupe pense l'inverse
puis lui il veut faire plus de demandes
toujours les mêmes au Canada on sait
tous c'est quoi le résultat là qui nous
attend mais
c'est un choix et c'est un choix qui
doit être soumis à l'électeurs parce que
ça a beaucoup d'incidence sur l'avenir
du Québec avez-vous l'impression que
c'est vous qui rallumez ce débat là où
on a l'impression qu'il y ait aussi
Québec solidaire est-ce que vous avez
laissé peut-être la place à Québec
solidaire dans ce débat il y a de la
place pour tout le monde mais je pense
que c'est l'actualité ce sont les deux
points quelques milliards qu'on envoie
dans les sables bitumineux de l'alberto
a même nos impôts les 6 milliards
manquants l'absence de contrôle et de
pouvoir en culture sur nos frontières
l'absence d'application de nos lois sur
les entreprises à Chartres fédéral la
loi 101 sur notre territoire à
s'applique pas l'absence d'application
de nos lois d'environnement l'actualité
nous ramène constamment l'existence d'un
gouvernement de trop moi je pense que
c'est légitime et super nécessaire de
mentionner qu'on devrait et qu'on un
jour on décidera par nous-mêmes comme
n'importe quel pays normal
bonjour bonjour
est-ce que c'est ce soir que les
souverainistes de la CAQ rentrent au
Bergheim
j'ai voulu est-ce que vous avez réussi
les convaincre c'est quand même simple
oui puis je leur ai pas parlé peut-être
vous je sais pas
moi j'ai voulu mener un débat sur
certaines questions essentielles avec
authenticité en donnant leur juste et
sur l'indépendance comme sur le français
François Legault avait pas de réponse à
mes interventions il n'avait pas d'autre
plan que de continuer dans un déclin de
la langue française qui est marqué
continue dans des échecs répétés avec le
fédéral donc ce sont des questions
légitimes et j'espère que j'en conviens
des gens qui sont indépendantistes de
revenir dans leur maison parce que la
porte est grande ouverte c'est la maison
du Parti québécois et est-ce que ce soir
que vous pensez que vous avez réussi à
gagner votre propre circonscription
je vais pas faire d'analyse je me suis
concentré à être moi-même puis être
clair sur les enjeux qui sont
déterminants à mes yeux pour notre
avenir
bonjour bonjour
qu'est-ce que ça vous donne de faire ça
je vais faire équipe avec Dominique
Anglade quand François Legault essayait
de lui couper la parole sur un sujet
fondamental je me suis montré ouvert à
tout le monde parce que notre but c'est
d'intéresser le plus possible les gens
la politique essentiellement obtenir
aussi un taux de participation élevé aux
élections puis il y a une manière de
faire de la politique pour que les gens
continuent à écouter s'intéressent à
l'avenir moi j'ai trouvé que pour la
démocratie c'est un débat qui était
simple puis
il y a pas de stratégie au-delà de ce
que vous pensez que les Québécois y
apprécient
des débats comme ceux-là sur cette des
réflexions puis de l’intérêt parce que
c'est notre avenir donc question ce sont
des vrais questions quand on parle de
nos tout-petits de la dignité des aînés
les soins de santé l'avenir de notre
langue c'est toutes des vraies choses
des choses importantes pour la suite
pour l'avenir
bonjour monsieur Saint-Pierre flamandon
François caramel Debois dans vos
publicités vous dites que vous voulez
réveiller le géant endormi de
l'indépendance c'est le mouvement en
fait qui est le géant notre mouvement
est un géant avez-vous réussi à
réveiller ou du moins
le sortir un peu de son sommeil ce soir
mais il est occupé de l'espace
normalement quand quelque chose dort on
le voit pas
il est occupé de l'espace parce que
lorsque je pose des questions pourtant
simple sur le français et sur notre
rapport avec Ottawa François Legault
change le sujet ou offre des réponses
qui sont les mêmes réponses qui ont
échoué au cours des quatre dernières
années donc c'est certain que il est là
la question elle est là elle est entière
et elle est légitime elle est
fondamentale elle dure depuis les
patriotes c'est le combat de c'est la
lutte légitime de René Lévesque de plein
de gens qui ont beaucoup donné pour une
cause qui demeure d'actualité et qui a
mes yeux est déterminante pour l'avenir
du Québec comme vous avez
parlé à Monsieur le goût du de ces
propos sur le monopole d'être contre la
souveraineté
semblait nier avoir dit ça au dernier
débat comment vous vous interprétez se
repositionnement là
je sais pas mais de tout évidence
il avait volontairement oublié ses
propos pourtant tellement clair de qui
essentiellement le mettait de l'avant
comme le chef le plus fédéraliste de
tous les chefs donc ensuite on peut
essayer de jouer sur les mots dire j'ai
pas dit ça il y avait des points 5
millions de téléspectateurs la semaine
dernière puis il y avait probablement
l'équivalent donc les gens suivent ça
puis
ils attirent les conclusions mais ce que
vous vous interprétez ça comme un chef
qui essaie de remettre la pâte à dents
dans le tube je vais avoir je vais
laisser les analystes faire cette
[Musique]
exercice là mais il est clair que il
tentait de nier les propos qu'il a tenu
la semaine dernière alors que tout le
monde en a été témoin je vais poser
juste une question je vais laisser du
temps à mes collègues anglophones
à la lumière de bottes ce soir est-ce
que François Legault vote oui ou non un
référendum s'il y en a un prochain il y
a pas de transparence
il y en a pas juste sur cette question
là
le déclin du français arrive quoi il
continue les mêmes politiques que ce qui
nous amène dans le déclin le plus
accéléré de l'histoire du Québec il y a
pas de réponse transparente de la part
de François Legault
[Musique]
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup